free appetizers he looks like we're live
hey ladies and gentlemen happy fourth of
July in the United States holiday today
I totally forgot here's the thing like
we were gonna do because like I said
originally we had planned to do a live
stream like every other episode so we
were actually gonna record this show
last night and then put it up on Tuesday
like normal but then time was like now
let's do it live yeah you know I mean if
we're gonna do it and we have an
audience might as well I kind of like
having an audience it does like I said
it does make easier in the sense that
one and I have so much you know editing
to do afterward and like you said if we
kind of get stuck or sidetracked or
something like that we can just like
answer questions it's like good to
interact and live time so yeah you know
I do do kind of like doing that and
we're doing a little bit earlier today
because I totally forgot that it was
good like fourth of July what I said hey
let's okay we'll do the live stream on
Saturday then I was like oh [ __ ] the
holiday so we didn't really want in case
the neighbors and [ __ ] we're doing
fireworks we wanted to like finish up
before it got too dark
yeah nico and debra on there hey you
guys and there's melody happy fourth of
July
yeah they're all piling in now yeah it's
like I don't know if people are gonna do
fireworks or not because it's been so
it's been raining all day so you know
and it's not like the the people that
used to live next door to us they I
think like every year they would buy
like three thousand dollars but the
fireworks and then they'd be back there
like shooting them off all night but
they moved away so now we have like
quiet people living in store so I don't
know if they're gonna blow anything up
tonight I got about it I got about two
hundred rounds of five five six
millimeter blanks I'll [ __ ] jump out
there at my m16 put the blank adapter on
and just fire up a bunch of blanks
neighbors send the [ __ ] cops and I
wouldn't advise it sound [ __ ] blanks
well that's the thing everybody's
probably gonna be shooting fireworks yes
he doesn't have and if maybe you guys
are on my my
personal Facebook Bebo said a very cute
video Fuki this morning who decided that
she was gonna hide well hide you know
I'm using that term loosely
underneath the bath mat like in the
bathroom next to my office and I think
she was surprised that we could actually
see her yeah it's just a bath mat yes
three by three feet she's hiding
underneath it look at you can see me
yeah I didn't really really like it
folder right and her but with Jen
Thornton anyways back Deborah Sandra
Tammy J Marcus
how does fuzz but handle this day I
think last year area bees nests is in
Maria that's Marie again okay I think
she I think last year she just hid under
the bed yeah really bothers her that
much not really I think it well because
she she kind of like freaks out but she
looks at us and sees that we're not
freaking out so we got twenty three in
yeah cool so that's a pretty good
turnout yeah yeah it'd probably be about
a three hour show depend on how much fun
we all have and how much money we're
making and how in how drunk I am how if
I can say one of these you know some day
this is so sad it's like every single
day like with pretty weekend days cuz I
can't really afford to sleep in like on
week date on weekdays so it's like I
always get up really early but weekends
like Saturday morning I'm always like
hey I'm gonna sleep in this is networks
and it never happens I always wake up
between 5:00 and 6:00 in the goddamn
morning and I can't go back to sleep and
it just makes me so so angry I fell
asleep with headphones on I wake up at
2:30 in the morning yeah and get a look
wreck somebody said something on the
headphones Alex Jones Yellin or some
[ __ ] like that well know how you can
sleep with him like living in your ears
shrieking holy reminds me of the army
well I cuz I can hear it go to the
headphones do
so it's gotta be really loud like no
brain if you want me to fall asleep yell
at me or put me or put me a smile on me
because I'm not yellow or jet engines
jet turbines whoa that sound you know
okay I'm not a turbine so [ __ ] cheap
I'm gonna tell you I'm not gonna tell
you when I'm gonna do it but you'll be
sleeping like you'll be snoring
everything like that and all of us I'm
gonna lean really really close your head
[Applause]
you might get punched I've I grabbed her
before in asleep yeah you know that a
while but yeah I thought I was fighting
somebody else you know just one time is
this is really funny but I was getting
up to go to work you know this was a few
years ago and you reached over and
grabbed my leg like when I was trying to
get out of bed yeah and I was like dude
I gotta go to work you got it like I say
nothing you know I was just kind of like
[Laughter]
but no you put me in any kind of jet
parrot jet-powered aircraft I'll fall
asleep except a commercial airliner that
isn't but it's got to be something
military I can't sleep on it really good
like a c5 galaxy or plus cuz it's my
[ __ ] knees or where you h1 or not
your [ __ ] ch-47 or blackhawk I'll
[ __ ] fall asleep quick yeah yeah he
went the doors open well that depends on
what it depends on what time of day with
the doors open I just [ __ ] love it I
find it if I can relax and I can't I
can't sleep with a bunch of noise I
can't sleep with a bunch of noise and I
can't see with a bunch of light I think
that's another thing that sucks about
the summer for me it's like white noise
yeah
yeah because it sounds like white noise
to me I mean another thing about summer
too is that one the Sun comes up at like
really early and like as soon as the Sun
comes up like my little eyes go blink
you know and like wake up and it's kind
of hot you know in this even though the
a/c is on but it's still like kind of
hot outside so I don't know I always
wake up early early it sucks so
I'm gonna try and stay awake on the
assignment I've had some caffeine today
but not all that much now since I didn't
know that we were gonna be actually
doing a live show on July 4th so I
didn't really do any themed topic cuz I
think last year for the show that we did
around the July 4th show we did like an
American History think Izumi's do like
Lost Colony of Roanoke or something like
that we did something like American
history base but I didn't really um plan
ahead so like I sex I didn't know I
thought July 4th to be over so we're
just doing a true-crime thing
I guess it's American in the sense that
these serial killers are Americans and
are killing other Americans so and these
are two that have not been caught yeah
so scary
watch everybody watch you back out there
although they say these ones are
probably older by now because this is
like in the 80s yeah what are you what
are you uh oh nothing I'm just saying
we're back on serial killers there's
some new [ __ ] coming out on that that
that that new unsolved mysteries series
was pretty good and had one UFO case on
it I like that they gave a shout out to
like the paranormal they do stories
which kind of sucks but maybe if they
get another season another season
they'll do it yeah if you guys haven't
seen the new unsolved mysteries it's
pretty good we might livestream a review
of that tomorrow because we binge like
the whole whole season it's not long
it's only what it was like six episodes
yeah what I liked is two kept the theme
song but they didn't even try and
replace the Robert Stack they're just
there's no there's no host yeah it's a
picture of Robert Stack eyes at the
beginning yeah yeah they just that's
fine that's a great background doesn't
meet a host well yeah that's the thing I
kind of figured I mean you could say
that it didn't seem as much like
unsolved mysteries because it didn't
have the hose now it just kind of seems
like a regular true crime show but I
wasn't really that bothered because you
know Robert Stack was so iconic and they
did replace him with other hosts later
on like after he died like Virginia
Madsen was on there and Dennis Farina or
whatever of the other guy was but um it
it just to me it seemed like he was so
so much a part of that original show
that if you tried so you put somebody
else in there I don't think it would
have worked another thing though is that
that that show is from a very 80s format
yeah if you had another guy in doing a
Robert Stack stand in fact it would just
seem like filler yeah you don't really
need that anymore those from the time
yeah cuz they would just talk about the
case introduce it and then put them at
the end to close it off you you really
didn't need Robert Stack yeah it was
kind of you know I mean he was just kind
of like a bonus since you don't have a
bonus right like a bonus and now you
don't have Robert Stack you don't really
eliminating it I think was the the best
way to go because it was a TV program
and TV programs from that error just
fluff yeah everything was padded out
fluffed and made longer than it should
because you're just trying to fill up
[ __ ] space yeah and this one's better
because I mean some of the other
unsolved mysteries like it usually had
like two or three or four even four
cases on there and I think it kind of
benefits from having a bit longer to
breathe because each episode just
focuses on one case and it's like 48
minutes or whatever so I mean there were
some good cases on there yeah it's good
it's good I liked it yeah it's not as
distinctive as the 80's ones were but
it's like you know it's more like just a
regular true crime and I think it's
maniac maniacs and that yeah that the
song isn't quite as intense is the
original they mellowed it out a little a
little bit it's good yeah I do like the
depth that though in the end the logo
too it's like almost exactly the same
but not as 80s looking my favorite one
was too was the UFO story yeah I like
that one the best yeah I liked a ball
but that was a wacky story yeah I never
heard that I never heard of it either
and I don't know if it's just because
like they said they didn't want to tell
anybody because they thought everyone
think there were knots or if it's just
because they got they all got together
they're gonna tell that's crazy
people in the town remembered it that's
true even though the cops didn't write
it down because they thought it was
[ __ ] that's true and it wasn't but
it was everything they talked about it
on the radio the local radio station
yeah that's right but they didn't they
recorded Oh
yeah they didn't say you know it's not
like nowadays everybody saves everything
real tape yeah hey we're just like now
it's expensive [ __ ] tape so something
happened a lot people saw it and then
some kids say they got abducted they
just they saw each other in the ship
even though they didn't know each other
but they well and later the one thing
that kind of makes me like I said I'm
usually a very very skeptical of alien
abduction stories but I will say that
maybe if something weird did happen to
them at least they didn't try to
embellish it to the to the point where
it's like you know they describe the
ship and the alien and you know the anal
Perot but everything they basically you
know they basically just came on and
said well you know we woke up and we
were just in this room when we saw like
some other kids there but that's all
they remember like they didn't like add
a bunch of extraneous yeah they didn't
remember seeing in the aliens yeah
nobody mentioned they saw each other and
then they woke up and then they woke up
somewhere else well no they were like
some of them were farther away put back
in their cars yeah that old lady and
stuff and that was one of the weirdest
things that the there was the lady the
mom and her mom of the kids were in the
back yeah and when they got put back in
the well they lost three hours and then
when they came back to like the grandma
was in the driver seat and the mom was
in the passenger seat yeah the grandma
didn't drive the gramma did drive and
even though mom had been driving aliens
put them back in the wrong order whoops
yeah like what I can't tell which one
goes where yeah just stuff them back in
there come on we actually do but yeah so
um anyway well like I said we'll
probably do like a matinee show or
something like that tomorrow and talk
about it I was gonna talk about there's
a new like Korean movie that they just
put up on shudder um and I was gonna
talk about that one too but I kind of
fell asleep that was watching it so I
might have to either watch it again or
skip it and do it another time but yes
it was like a possession maybe so
alright so let me do a couple of shout
outs and then we'll get into talking
about these serial killers these
unidentified serial killers two
different cases that we're gonna be
talking about so I actually have a
couple of shout outs
we had three PayPal donation
this week we had one from Gregg so thank
you very much one from Melanie who I
think is here I just saw her in the
comments oh thank you very much Melanie
and also one from a new person who I
think this is the first time they've
contacted us someone named Logan so
thank you very much all of you guys for
the donation yeah we got I think we got
most of the shirt information we're
gonna be placed in order for shirts soon
yeah I got a dude yeah if you're a
twenty dollar nut patron or you know
you've given us like you know
significant amounts of money on PayPal
we're sending out shirts I sent out like
emails and you know messages on patreon
and stuff like that so just making sure
that I have what sighs as you want if I
have your mailing address correct and
stuff because I know some people on
patreon like that give a lot of money
but they don't they didn't put their
address in there like a company with
people so I just wanted to make sure
that I had everyone's correctly because
I think probably Monday I'm gonna order
the blanks and then we'll you have to
get we have screen yeah I gotta get a
frame you just have to we just have to
get a couple of frames we got three new
designs we got a new 13 o'clock design
it looks [ __ ] awesome it's our best
one best one yet thank you and got two
more designs come one of them's gonna be
a 13 o'clock Snake Plissken design which
is the Ford Cobra symbol but instead of
Cobra in the front it just says Plissken
yeah alright as one of them it looks
really funny it's gonna be a bootleg
Ford Cobra available only from [ __ ]
us alright and in the back and probably
have another little 13 o'clock logo on
the back and then the other one would be
is gonna be a Weyland industries yeah
[ __ ] t-shirt and I think maybe a
weyland-yutani oh yeah I did two
versions I did like the one that just
says Weyland Corp and I did the one that
says weyland-yutani that looks more like
this yeah on the back up near the foot
and the small the back there'll be a
little 13 o'clock logo because I like
those shirts I liked like those movies
so that's a we wanted to do some
crossovers and those are our crossovers
yeah yeah so from the front they'll just
look like there's something out of the
movie but on the back you see it's got
our label on it yeah good idea
and I do like the new 13 o'clock shirt
that I did yeah it looks great I think
it came out
also you know that'll be the next one
that we can do all right so I think that
was all the shoutouts do you have any no
DJ maniac says was it a Greg with three
G's no it was just a regular that's a
good idea
canon film logo yeah we can do a cannon
films
and I'll do it we'll put a 13 o'clock on
the little back of it like a little 3x3
[Laughter]
yeah I think you're doing that see
alright so the first case we're gonna
talk about is the Connecticut River
Valley killer now this was an
unidentified serial killer who they
think was responsible for a large number
of murders in mostly around Claremont
New Hampshire but there were some like
in other like in Vermont and other
things too starting in like the late
1970s going into the 80s some of the
cases you know a lot of the cases are
linked just in the sense of you know
this area and them being stabbed and you
know things of that nature but there are
a couple that they're not sure if they
were part of the series or not now
there's a really really good book about
this case called the shadow of death and
I got the e-book a couple days ago and I
just like read it like in two sittings
like it probably took me like five or
six hours and it's like a fascinating
fascinating book hold on I just thought
of something what Jesus would you guys
like an MTV t-shirt like Blaine from
predator one head remember that [ __ ]
black t-shirt with a [ __ ] white MTV
logo on the front of it the classic one
yeah that but Jesse the body Ventura was
wearing from thank you to the one in
Jesse the body was wearing and put in
protein I'd have to say I mean it was it
like the the standards I think it is
just a white on black okay I think I
think you guys might like that
cuz I had I had a whole bunch of MTV
shirt someone's grown up my dad worked
for cable it was the 80s MTV logo yeah
yeah I could probably do I could
probably do like a 13 o'clock
version of that you know what I mean
yeah
like with the big 13 kind of like this
but then like yes let me be someone's
mom and then maybe like a little astral
I was I don't know I was thinking maybe
just putting a little different label on
the back of the 13 o'clock label back
here yeah I mean some things some things
you can't that's the thing you don't
want to get into like copyright issues I
guess it doesn't really matter because
we're not we're not selling them online
and I said on my line we get we're kind
of close so kind of giving them away
I say yeah and it's a bootleg shirt just
for fans email that's true okay yeah
because it's canon out of business you
know what I don't know
yeah our cam and films all around I
don't think so I mean I'm sure I mean
their heyday was the 80s and 90s but I
don't know I mean I would be very
surprised if they were still around yeah
but we'll see I'm not sure how
protective MTV is of that logo one of
those old logos like that yeah I don't
even know what MTV's logo looks like
yeah I haven't watched it that's that
wrong it's not like we're selling it
that's true right I don't think the
print printers would have any problem
printing that out yeah would they
depends okay
I mean we I used to work in a print shop
and like you you'd get some people would
come in like all the time and they're
like hey I want to do these like bootleg
you know Disney character
yeah I can type in [ __ ] and we'd have to
tell them not to and then they get like
really you know upset with us and I'm
like look man it's like we're gonna get
sued so it's like print that [ __ ] out at
home if you're like that [ __ ] dead set
on it yeah Maria said my mother was born
in Claremont and raised in Keene still
have a lot of family there which were a
lot of these murders took place these
nests of Sand Canyon films was gone yeah
that's why I figured yeah I figured I
don't think that'd be a problem
yeah and weyland-yutani and Weyland
industries we're never trademarks well
because it's not like a real oh honey
it's just like a within universe type of
thing and I've seen like tons of other
shirts with that [ __ ] on it so it's like
I'm not really all that worried about it
right it's just an idea
yeah so alright so
so like I said this is an unapprehended
serial killer who killed you know
several people in this area like from
late 70s to mid to late 80s now before I
kind of get into the you know canonical
Connecticut River Valley killer murders
this was kind of interesting to me
because I didn't actually know this
until I read shadow of death that around
the same time that the Connecticut River
Valley killings were going on there was
another serial killer who was caught
later on now he was not the same guy
that did the other crimes because it's
like the mo was a little bit different
and he was caught like you know prior to
like some of the other victims getting
killed but there's this guy named Gary
Schaefer now he was from Vermont and he
was um like in this weird like
fundamentalist Christian grew the Christ
adelphia Church and so he started out he
was in the Navy and while he was in the
Navy he got in trouble for like arson
and drug possession and stuff like that
he got caught he tried to do an insanity
plea I guess but the Navy said no and he
got discharged now the weird thing about
him was that he seemed like really quiet
really normal really religious like no
one thought that much about you know him
being a weirdo or anything like that
everyone just thought oh he kind of kept
to himself and everything but apparently
um he was a super [ __ ] creepy rapist
and murderer because in 1979 he
kidnapped raped and murdered a 13 year
old girl named Cheri Nastasia and this
girl lived in an apartment complex in
Springfield that which I'm assuming is
in Vermont that was owned by Schafer's
brother he also raped and killed another
little girl named Teresa Fenton that was
in 1981 and then in 1982 he tried to
kidnap this 17 year old girl named
Deanna Buxton and basically I can't
remember if he raped her or not but he
basically drove around with her in his
car like he had her at gunpoint and he
drove her
they're in his car for like two hours
and like he was gonna rape her and kill
her
now she actually ended up getting away
and gave the description to the cops um
but they didn't have like enough
evidence to hold him even though they
have like a good description of him in
his card it was like that because
apparently um you know the girl that got
kidnapped she was like she was in the
car for a really long time she knew
exactly what the car looked like she
knew all this other kind of stuff and
the car wrecked like not too long after
she got away so he like changed his car
out and also it took them a long time to
like coordinate and all this other kind
of [ __ ] but then in April of 1983 he
Gary Schaeffer he kidnapped this girl
named Katherine Katie Richards and this
was kind of [ __ ] up because Katie
Richards was like with her little friend
and they were like riding their bikes or
you know walking down the street or
whatever and he basically grabbed Katie
and so the little friend like saw the
whole thing happened and like she
[ __ ] took off you know what I mean
and like told him like what he looked
like and what the car looked like and
everything now he took Katie to like
some kind of remote area made her give
him a [ __ ] this is a little girl and
then smashed her skull in with a rock
Diane and they found her later out like
the next day now finally you know she's
like I said the friend had given a
description of him in a description of
the car and people around town like
we're pretty sure that that's you know
that Gary Schaeffer was the dude that it
was now what ended up happening was that
you know they arrested him and then like
the mother of one of the victims who was
in the same church as him like sent him
a letter and was like you know basically
saying like God would want you to
confess because he knows that you did it
or whatever yeah and this was apparently
all it took he broke down and he
confessed so he actually did plead
guilty to kidnapping sexual assault
second degree murder and he did he
actually like he got a plea bargain I
guess because so he got away with the
therese offense and murder even though
he said he did it but that was like down
as a plea bargain now he actually got a
sentence of 30 years to life he got sent
to Leavenworth
now I bring them you to be killed yeah
no [ __ ] so I bring that up because this
is I mean this area of like New
Hampshire Vermont this area was a very
low crime area and so it just goes to
show that this particular time you know
when this guy got caught and there were
also the you know the valley killings
going on as well it was kind of one of
those things where and you know this is
almost become a cliche at this point but
like these kind of small towns like
where everyone's like friendly and kind
of knows each other nobody locks their
doors blah-dee-blah but in the late 70s
in the early 80s when this [ __ ] started
happening it was almost kind of like you
know this was this areas like loss of
innocence type thing so because they not
even had they not only had one serial
killer they had two of them running
around but it was just as a tease
yeah because they caught this guy but
the Connecticut River Valley killer as
they call him has not been caught to
this day so they had they have a couple
of suspects but um as you know as far as
they know it's like you know they still
have not caught this person oh well you
can watch don't show him the card that
you gave me we showed it I think we
showed it on your birthday show okay but
in case you guys didn't see this look
it's this hilarious birthday card that I
gave Tom it's like I said I think I
showed it on the birthday show look at
this it looks just like Pookie was a
bass Pookie was so excited that I saw
this little kitty and I was like oh my
god that looks just and that's like -
okay look at that [ __ ] look on his
which that's what cracked me up it's
like it's real even though it's even
though the card was for you I keep it in
my office right next the thing just
because it cracks gonna alan take me to
your leader
yeah yeah so the first whoa whoa what
miss you cement flash ball thank you
very much excellence on me I hate
drinking alone
it's pay spooky yeah yeah you always
hear about towns being described as a
place where people don't lock their
doors and then X happened people just
lock your doors yeah I never really
understood that um I don't know I guess
because it's not like I grew up in a you
know haven of crime or anything like
that but it's like I don't remember a
time when we didn't lock the doors up
thanks Luna you name's pastel are you uh
are you Brazilian that's a Brazilian
name
yeah you're you must be a couple ahead
of me
no what okay Tomic to my messages yeah
for some reason it runs a little bit
slow yeah we need a Pookie shirt I know
we really do need a poky shirt I need
like a really good the color space Pooky
Pooky
I'm still laughing I'm still laughing at
her under that her helmet in the photo
is just a [ __ ] takeout yeah Chinese
takeout card yeah like I said that
totally looks like nothing book you
would do because she doesn't give me
[ __ ] like that all the time yeah yeah
all right so the first of the canonical
Connecticut River Valley killings
happened in October of 1978 although I
will admit that the thing about this is
that they didn't actually link this
crime to the other ones because it was a
little bit farther was like if it was in
a different jurisdiction now the cops at
the time like when all these crimes
started happening particularly like in
the early 80s they did like link them
and look over because I guess like
there's like from New Hampshire and
Vermont it was only like a river in
between them but and they were pretty
good about like sharing information like
between the police departments however
for some reason this one slipped between
the cracks somehow and this was one that
they missed out on so they didn't
actually know that this murder was part
of the series until after the last
victim had been killed but now that they
know like we're going back in time so
I'm just trying to keep it kind of you
know chronological so the first victim
over twenty fourth 1978 this was Kathy
Milliken now she was a birdwatcher and
she had gone to the Chandler Brook
wetland Preserve and was taking pictures
of some rare ducks that she had heard
were supposed to be there and while she
was there apparently someone had been
watching her stalking her and murdered
her so she was found the next day only a
few yards from where she had last been
seen in New London New Hampshire she had
been stabbed
29 times which is kind of a signature of
this killer a lot of stab wounds usually
in the throat and he also has a tendency
to leave like a v-shape of stab wounds
in the abdomen he does that as well not
every single time but that's a lot of
the signature that's what it is so now
even though her clothes were kind of
like some of them were like torn off her
or like thrown around and had been like
kind of disarranged but they determined
that she had most likely not been raped
so they're wondering if this is someone
who like I said kind of like BTK who
we're like the murdering or the stabbing
is the actual sexual release rather than
actually raping someone you know what I
mean because it seemed like it seems
like this killer just got off on this
stabbing BTK was like that well I'm just
saying in the sense that he didn't
usually rape because I think yeah the
victims sometimes he like jerked off on
that they were dead but he didn't rape
them because I think the one that really
didn't have sex with anybody was [ __ ]
zodiac uh not to when he just went
around shooting people shooting people
and stabbing people mostly shooting
people yeah I don't think so Sam had sex
with anybody either
no not that not that I remember well
like I said and we've kind of talked
about this before but I mean usually the
classic quote-unquote serial killer is a
rapist - yes - but just because they
don't necessarily rape their victims in
the classical sense of raping good in
the metaphysical sense
right that's what I'm saying and it's
like and I think that that was one of
the things that they came up with the
profile for the for the valley killer
was that this is someone who gets a
sexual charge from the actual killing
from the actual stabbing because he
stabs the victims a lot of times yeah so
somebody that might be someone who is
sexually aroused by blood flow basically
like a whole bunch of blood coming out
because like I said one of the things
that he does easy stabs him in the
throat so the next victim of this killer
this happened on July 25th 1981 this was
37 year old Mary Elizabeth Critchley now
she was a University of Vermont students
she disappeared near Interstate 91 which
is at the border of master Massachusetts
and Vermont she had actually been
hitchhiking which a couple of these
women were August 9th which you know
which a couple weeks later her body was
found in the woods in unity New
Hampshire now this one they weren't real
sure what the cause of death was just
because she was so decomposed but where
she was found where she was last seen I
believe they did do some you know later
on they did some more forensic thing it
saw like some you know stab with like on
the bones and things like that so they
did presume that she had probably been
stabbed to that's because I don't think
they could find it like any other method
that she had been killed the next one
happened May 30th 1984 this was a woman
named Bernice Courtemanche which it's
weird because it's it's a French name
obviously but in the in the book he said
that it was pronounced more like cooter
Marsh which to me seems very strange
because it's kind of not how it's
spelled but I was just like whatever
it's okay I'm just saying that's what he
said in the book on all those journey
now this this girl was only 16 she was a
nurse's aide which is something that
kind of came up a lot in this case I
think and and I don't know how how much
of this relates to like I I don't know
how much of this is coincidence because
I think people had the
deception once a lot of the women were
killed that all or most of them were
nurses or works at hospitals to some
degree and that maybe the killer was
targeting them for that reason but I'm
not sure it's hard to say if that was
maybe why because it does seem like two
or three of the victims were nurses or
worked in nursing in some capacity which
seems I don't know it seems like a
little too much to be a coincidence but
it's possible that it could just be a
coincidence because some of the other
ones were not so but this woman was a
nurse's aide I believe she worked in a
like a old folks home you know I mean
like a you know what do you call those
where yeah like yeah a hospice or like
you know an old folks home
yeah a convalescent home something like
that so she was apparently seen in
Claremont um she was hitchhiking also
she was going to see her boyfriend in
Newport and was seen hitchhiking along
route 12 now she didn't get to her
boyfriend's house
and was reported missing she was
actually not found for almost two years
her body was found in April 1986 a
fisherman found her remains
now she was very decomposed obviously
because it had been two years but they
were able to determine that she had
probably been stabbed to death just like
the others because of you know Nick's on
the bones and whatnot the next one
occurred
July 20th 1984 this was 27 year old Alan
Freed also a nurse she worked at Valley
Regional Hospital now she had actually I
guess she didn't have a phone at her
house so it was kind of her habit to
stop and use pay phones because you know
the 80s nobody had cell phones back then
so she had actually stopped at this
grocery store that had a pay phone in
the father the grocery store was closed
because it was kind of late at night she
was coming home from work I believe and
she stopped at this pay phone and called
her sister now she had been talking to
her sister for like you know for quite a
while for like almost an hour and
the sister said that she that that Ellen
said
that's strange and then the sister was
like what's strange and she's like oh
this car just went past and then it went
past again and she just thought it was a
little weird
she's like hang on a minute I'm gonna go
like make sure my car serve just start
the engine of my car so I can just jump
in and you know and leave if I have to
like in case that guy pulls in here so
apparently she did that she went over
there she started the car she was only
like a few steps away from the car like
I said it was just in front of the
grocery store so she and then she comes
back and talks to her sister a little
bit more and then they hang up and then
she disappears so the following day she
did not show up to work and her car was
found abandoned a few miles away from
the phone booth where she had last been
then in September of that year they
found her remains in the woods near
Sugar River she had been raped in this
particular prom probably had been
sexually assaulted and had died from
multiple stab wounds the next one was
July 10th 1985
this was 27 year old Eva Morse she was a
single mother she was also hitchhiking
same road route 12
as one of the other victims she was
reported missing after she didn't show
up at her destination 1986 about a year
later her remains were found by loggers
her body was found only about 500 yards
from where Elizabeth Critch Lee's body
had been found back in 1981 she had also
been stabbed they found evidence of stab
wounds in her neck I don't know if she
was sexually assaulted or not I would
presume not or they were not able to
determine if she had been now this
particular case this is one that
happened this happened in May 1986 and
at first because they he went into this
a lot in the book shadow of death they
kind of went back and forth over whether
to include this case or not because on
the surface it seemed a tad dissimilar
but the more they thought about it the
more they
that maybe this was you know the same
killer one of the same ones in the
series now this was a woman named Linda
Moore and she was actually at her house
she lived in Saxton's River Vermont and
she was outside she was either most of
the sources I saw say she was doing yard
work but in the book they said she was
just sunbathing like she had her chair
and her flip-flops or whatever and she
had just been kind of laying out in the
yard getting some Sun now she only lived
a little way from interstate 19 and the
house where she lived it was like it was
on this corner and I guess like it was
kind of a distinctive house like you
could see the yard like so she was out
sunbathing in the front yard like
everyone would have seen her that was
driving by is what I'm saying so so she
was outside apparently her husband who
was at work he called her and he was
like okay well this dude from work is
gonna stop by the house to get a check
from you he was picking up the check
because he was going to dump some stuff
and they needed a check for the dump
fees or whatever so he's like so he's
gonna stop by and get them and she was
just kind of like okay whatever I'll be
here now apparently that that guy was
like a little bit ahead of the husband
the husband and the and the other
employee get to the house a little while
later they go into the house and the
wife is dead
inside the house she has been stabbed
many many times and it looked like I
mean it looked like a super like a
brutal attack like somebody just came in
there and just like stabbed the [ __ ] out
of her they said that she was probably
dead like in a couple of minutes
although they did say that she looked
like she had like fought savagely
against the attacker but that he just
like stabbed her and stabbed her and
stabbed her and she's just like bled out
like in a in just a minute or so now at
first I usually would in situations like
this they were looking at the husband as
the prime suspect
but it was determined like through work
records and witness statements and you
know mileage and all this other kind of
stuff there's like there's no way that
he could have done it he was at work
provably you know he
with this other guy like at the time she
would have been killed now even though
there was a at this point there had been
a task force a small task force that was
put together to look into these murders
because like I said they they didn't
really know to link them until a bit
later on which is usually the case in
serial killer cases because you know you
don't have enough cases to like you know
establish a pattern or anything but at
this point they did have a small task
force which included a guy named John
Philbin who was a psychologist and he
was like helping them with profiling now
initially like I said they thought
because this woman was killed in her own
home that this didn't really seem to fit
the pattern of the other Valley killer
crimes but the more they thought about
it the more they thought that maybe this
one was the same killer not just because
of the you know you know the savagery of
the stabbing which was just very similar
to the other cases but also they pointed
out they're like well most of the other
women that were killed were you know
lured from somewhere so they were
operating under the assumption that
perhaps the killer had passed this
particular house had seen her or had
been watching her for a time and was
planning on luring her out of the house
to kill her somewhere else but for
whatever reason didn't get to do that
either because she fought him or
somebody came by or something like that
and so he just killed her and took off
you know before he would have taken her
somewhere else like he did with the
other victims because like I said that's
that was another thing that he would do
was he would you know take them
somewhere else like put them in his car
and drive them somewhere else and kill
them so in this case there had been some
witnesses that saw a guy that was kind
of hanging around the house and they
thought that he looked fishy or whatever
so they said well he looked like a kind
of a stocky dude dark hair he seemed to
be like hanging around the neighborhood
they said that he had a bright blue
backpack or a knapsack said he was kind
of young between 20 and 25 years old
clean-shaven and
wearing dark horror and glasses this
dude was never found
it was DB cooper very well did he ever
bright blue back there is where them
horn rimmed glasses you will never be
found see those glasses and then that's
all they remember and then the man
vanishes yeah pro tip for ya whoever
psyche wants to be somewhere and not
just have one really distinctive you
know just saying that dominates your
whole just DB cooper on out of this
[ __ ] they will never find you I
wonder if like criminals have figured
that out but it's like if you wear it
has to be a removable thing obviously
but if you wear something really crazy
like a viking helmet or something like
that and something that'll get people to
focus on that detail and that's like all
because seriously if i saw a dude
walking around with a [ __ ] viking
helmet on that's probably all I would
remember there's one remember his face
there's something called tradecraft
tradecraft some spies use and it's a lot
of little techniques to become invisible
or not to be noticed and one of the
things that they'll do is they'll just
wear that's kind of the opposite they'll
kind of wear something that is just
super super [ __ ] common and they'll
carry a plastic bag there's something in
it yeah and you'll just be [ __ ]
invisible because you got that plastic
bag and then you walk by a certain area
and then you go to the you know like say
like somebody you're trying to avoid or
let's say you're trying to somebody's
tail on you or you think somebody's
tailing you want to give them the slip
you take that outfit and then you go to
the [ __ ] bathroom and in that plastic
bag is another [ __ ] set of clothes
like a hat and a shirt and you switch
the hat and shirt out and put your old
shirt back in that bag and just walk
right back out and they wouldn't notice
you well I can feel it because you just
changed a shirt at yeah you weren't
wearing a hat before but there's a
certain kind of guy that can do it you
can't have any distinguishable features
it tend to become you know kind of kind
of
frumpy guys I just don't yeah don't you
just have to look like yeah dude right
you don't look like you don't look like
Daniel Craig I got a James Bond that guy
will never be forgotten he just stands
out too much well yeah you know so it's
it's quite the opposite it's like a guy
you wouldn't really know this yeah they
do that kind of stuff yeah you just have
to look like like you said just some
prime know dude I don't want to say
that'd be rude you have to look like
nothing
yeah well it's not what should look like
nothing but just not have anything that
make you stand out people's eyes just go
right over you yeah women just go right
over you're not good-looking you're not
ugly just yeah you're just there you're
not even noticeable right I've sometimes
think about this because I'm not real
good at like noticing people because
usually it's like I want people leave me
alone so I'm just gonna leave everyone
else they don't do but it's like
sometimes I mean cuz I write about true
crime and everything sometimes it'll
occur to me maybe I should start like
looking at [ __ ] like really
closely and I can't help but look at
[ __ ] and then like try to like I
mean sometimes I'll do it like obviously
if somebody's acting like [ __ ]
sketchy or something yeah I'm gonna look
at that [ __ ] dude memorize over the
years Jenni doesn't know how I do it but
I've sized a [ __ ] off just in a
few minutes and I know everybody needs
to be able to do that still have time
it's just because the average person is
very superficial but the average person
has a hundred IQ that's dumb and then
half the people even dumber than that so
just because you're superficial and
you're dumb that isn't doesn't give you
any special powers you want to be
superficial and [ __ ] intelligent
that's a [ __ ] how the whole secrets
apps a combination usually doesn't
happen because intelligent people are
trained to be deep yummy and to not be
superficial though though don't just
judge people know if you're intelligent
and you just [ __ ] very superficial
you can cold read somebody and size them
right up by what they're wearing their
accents [ __ ] their physical builds
you can you know is just that's how a
lot of people do it yeah yeah it's very
superficial somebody say this were a
reversible jacket yeah say well just go
look up tradecraft
you're talking about the vertical
jacket may not work because the average
person doesn't remember the color - well
then remember you the outline and the
shapes of things you know I mean they
may not even notice that the color of
the jacket changed they're not that
observant that's what I mean I probably
wouldn't I mean like I said unless
somebody's like acting really weird it
was usually things like they put hat a
hat on yeah and they totally change the
top but they have that damn plastic bag
and carrying a plastic bag kind of
erases you there's something about cover
dy that is just because it looks like
you're doing like you're doing something
purposeful I think because it makes you
look harmless yeah it's like oh I'm just
I just have my shopping right and then
there's another thing that can make you
look invisible just carrying a clipboard
Cape carrying a clipboard and and an
orange vest and maybe like a [ __ ] hat
like a [ __ ] hardhat you could
probably go walk into all different kind
of places and nobody asks you any
questions give anybody any idea if you
had a clipboard a cup of coffee uh
orange vest and a [ __ ] white yeah
because you looked like you had a
purpose you look like you're supposed to
be there yeah they'll say hey how you
doing and you could probably walk all
through okay I'm gonna go kill everybody
and they don't know what they don't know
what you're doing yeah and you know you
got or you could probably dress like a
mailman and go anywhere in that mail man
you got like a suppressed Matt Tannen
[ __ ] [ __ ] performance assays you
don't get funny ideas and you [ __ ]
walk out dressed like a mailman
delivery oh that shit's been thought of
that's not her that's what I mean yeah
it's like I'm sure that Assad was really
good at that I mean I'm sure that like
anybody would know well because you see
[ __ ] all the time where people that are
trying to you know like bank robbers or
something like that they're trying to
get into more steal diamonds or whatever
they dress like workmen yeah you know I
mean because no one questions that know
if there's a bunch of you and you're
carrying stuff yeah they're just like oh
okay
I remember reading this book it was a
long time ago so please forgive me but
it was about this really really daring
like diamond heist in a hurry or
anything like that but so I kind of was
like yeah all right
oh man baby trying to finish the
he tried bees nests but they actually
well they were in it for the long the
long game because they actually did not
only dress up like workmen but they
actually got in there for like several
weeks ahead of time
so they could like case the joint they
could like set up [ __ ] for later and all
this other [ __ ] so I kind of like had to
admire their their gumption you know
that they actually like and they did get
away with a bunch of the money but I
think a bunch of them got caught that
although a couple of them didn't get
caught and they got away with like a
billion dollars or something like some
ridiculous amount like in gems or
whatever alright so let's get back to
him is a killer mailman the scarlet cost
Sherlock Holmes also uh oh yeah there
was a killer mailman in five days of the
Condor that's right I was one of the
that's an old trick see I've been like
four there was a brief time as her mafia
used that too because remember when
there was like that brief time where a
couple of male men like went crazy and
like shot place up and everyone was
talking about going postal I don't even
remember what year that was in the
eighties or nineties sometime so
probably you wouldn't have wanted to
dress up like a mailman during that time
period like with that whole [ __ ]
thing was that but the guys supposed to
make it a delivery you got a bag yeah so
you can get close to somebody you're
asking for some I got a delivery for
this guy got delivered this guy they'll
let you into a scene if I'm killing yeah
you know mafia did it yeah not just but
I think it was a [ __ ] israeli mossad
thing first well yeah like I said that's
that's what you're trying to do is just
you know trying to not have anybody like
no right we're a dennis costume with a
bobble head and everything but yeah
alright so let's get back to this okay
so the next one the next one happened
January 10th 1987 and this was a woman
named Barbara Agnew she was also a nurse
like I said so that's kind of where this
perception came from that all of the
victims were nurses they weren't but a
lot of them were nurses or worked at a
hospital at like some capacity oh thank
you very much thank you very much thank
you / Bob Dale JM that's Dan I think
that's I think that stands yeah yeah
okay 20 pounds pretty sure 20 pounds
nice that's big money much a special
bunny yeah overseas mine that's kind of
one thing I wish they would do with our
money over here I wish it wasn't all the
same color
yeah it was awesome you're so caring I
haven't seen cash I got in there already
said it to me yeah but yeah we don't
really care all that much but I do like
the different colored notes and stuff I
thought that was so cool well it's like
you know easier to sell I like him
different sizes too because then if you
you know if you're visually impaired you
can you can quickly like take it you
don't have to have somebody else like
take all your money out cuz you know
which ones which I just think it's funny
they're trying to make all these
political statements behind you it are
gonna put on oh we're gonna take Jackson
off there we're gonna put Booker T
Washington and some [ __ ] like that on
[ __ ] on the 20 I think Jackson's on
twenty Jack's on twenty doesn't matter
nobody's seen [ __ ] bills in [ __ ]
10 years in the United States
everything's electronic that's how I
mean it's like [ __ ] 21st century where
yeah [ __ ] about that money and
especially like I said especially
nowadays with you [ __ ] cash got
nobody wants your dirty ass cash with
all to know the germs on it the futures
gonna that's that fake [ __ ] that's
that fake Federal Reserve [ __ ] money
there's nothing behind that that's
that's a Keynesian pulling money out of
the [ __ ] paper just free money
alright it's monopoly money that's
coming out of there the real money of
the futures cryptocurrency that's gonna
be real money you watch that's just how
it's gonna that's how that's how the
futures gonna be yeah we're bad you live
in interesting times I bet so yeah I
gotta pay me in [ __ ] Bitcoin Bitcoin
real money that's not they're gonna
that's what's gonna get to we're in
interesting times yeah you watch well
like I said I said I think now
cryptocurrencies now are just like used
mostly to buy illegal [ __ ] but you know
yeah you know I got storm's off there
it's not just illegal stuff it stuffed
it
well stuff that's like in the great
crime gray area sometimes they don't
want you to do that or you know we can
truth and it's not so much the law it's
certain corporate platforms don't want
to be involved in that transaction you
know that means it's not the government
it's somebody who runs some bay doesn't
like it there's a [ __ ] with
don't like man you're a [ __ ]
corporations you shouldn't be telling
people what to do you know that yeah
yeah cryptocurrency but sander says I
saw a TV show where they send people in
white working clothes into stores and
they carried multiple washing machines
out of the stores nobody stopped them no
even though yeah see that's what I mean
it's yeah if you look like you're
supposed to be there you can't act all
furtive and jump like that you just got
to go in there like yep I'm this is
where I'm supposed to be well [ __ ] if I
even have like some art thieves and
stuff like that that you just walk in
they just walk in and like a work there
and they just take the [ __ ] off the wall
they walk in with a [ __ ] briefcase
and looking nice and looking like they
kind of work there and they put a they
throw away a tarp
yeah the painting cover it up and then
they take it off the wall walk away and
right in front of people we need to work
on this you need to work on this man he
walks right out the front door and hold
it for ransom it proves it to have it
and then they even get arrested for it
didn't go out I don't have it but I I
think I know who has yeah they always
pull that guy's yeah I've read a lot of
books about art that yeah if I find that
it's like art thieves and diamond
thieves I find it very smart I find them
very fascinated if I think if you let me
go I can I can find out where it is for
a certain amount of money I can get back
yeah and then [ __ ] and he's in the
cell they don't believe him and all of a
sudden he goes just go back to your
office in a couple days if you yeah in a
couple days you're gonna get a little
piece of the corner over there gonna cut
it off you'll see and when you get that
call me and then [ __ ] dude in the
mail inspector gets a piece of the
[ __ ] painting it's all [ __ ] they have
it yeah he doesn't admit to having it he
just says I think I might know who has
it
I'm not involved in this but good thing
you arrested me because I'm the only guy
that can get it back for you yeah give
me the money and I'll go get it for you
they've got like a whole thing at all
down yeah because like I said I've read
several books about art heists and they
pretty much all have them yeah yeah and
then they have one day there's a master
at it and [ __ ] and he's an art
[ __ ] just he knows everything about
art and he's a [ __ ] master thief and
he doesn't give [ __ ] a bus spent in a
year or two in prison he does not give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because he knows he's gonna
give it four or five million dollars
eventually yeah so he just did a couple
years in prison if I knew I was gonna
have five million dollars and I got out
he was he was sweating this museum out
so hard behind a it was a van Gogh they
stole I think was a van Gogh's the idol
well yeah and I go for the [ __ ] yeah
and he got millions for it they know
that his team stole it
yeah he had a team of people but well
yeah you kind of got to have to do he
had done it more than once you know it
was a national treasure yeah what are
they gonna do they had him in there for
two or three years and he goes you keep
me here for all this time it's not gonna
matter you know you want your painting
back you're gonna have to let me go and
I'll go get the painting for you we
should do a show about the Isabella
Gardner heist yeah because that was a
fascinating they [ __ ] there was a
whole bunch of him like he said it was a
team they were pelled down through the
[ __ ] ceiling yeah and they took a
bunch of [ __ ] and they haven't got it
back yet I can't stand a thief I hate a
thief but I certain caliber a thief that
I respect that's what I mean there's
some kind of romance about like like I
said I'm fascinated by like art heist
like diamond heist like if they don't
hurt anybody they're not stealing from
them I mean they're stealing from a
bunch of rich people in Italy so I can't
feel that they're usually stealing from
a nation-state that's usually to this
deal from because it's some kind of a
national art work that they still some
kind of national treasure from A+ you
have to admire like the [ __ ] planning
and like just the the hutzpah that like
goes into it it's like yeah there's like
something really like romantic about
that and they're usually their main guy
and that the main guy the [ __ ] brains
behind it all it's his [ __ ] mission
and he's the one that's gonna go to jail
behind it and he's the one that's gonna
get most of the money yeah so it's not
like he's making other people do his
dirty work
yeah you know he might spend two years
behind bars
please gonna get that [ __ ] twenty
million dollars like I said you know
that's like two years in prison that's
like 420 million yeah well if you know
you're gonna get 20 million he's get out
you'd be a [ __ ] cakewalk yeah he's
basically
holding a [ __ ] priceless piece of art
for hostage yeah I mean like I said I
think there's there's just something to
be said for these types of Heights
yes like if they start like killing
people like you know innocent people
there's like guards up that was [ __ ]
Robin Robin poor people that's the
[ __ ] lowest that's what it yeah it's
like don't do that ah yeah it's like
don't break into like some poor person's
house to take their bike or that I can
rob somebody somebody's [ __ ] business
[ __ ] got a hard working [ __ ] you
know restaurant tour or some [ __ ] like
that yeah it's like you know it's like
like steel like small potatoes anyway
right like I said the crew that like did
this big diamond heist I think it was an
Antwerp and Belgium and and and it was
it was hard because it's like they have
a whole diamond district there and
everything is like this [ __ ] the
whole neighborhood like where all the
diamond dealers are like is in a
lockdown they have like [ __ ] these
you know these metal pipes that like
come out of the [ __ ] ground like so
you can't drive in there and like all
this other kind of [ __ ] so the fact that
they were able to I mean it took him
like several months of planning and like
kind of getting in there as workmen and
like getting jobs there like in various
capacities so they was like a lot of
planning involved in this and they
pulled off like a gigantic ice like I
said it was like I think I can't
remember but it was like a billion died
he was like a billion dollars in like
diet was just diamonds all kind of
different gems and like all kind of
different [ __ ] and I think they did find
some of the [ __ ] and they did find a
couple of the dudes but they didn't find
all of them and they still don't know
where they are but like I said you know
that's like that's rich people [ __ ] they
just went in there and like got all
these diamonds out of these like [ __ ]
rich [ __ ] you know in like
boxes or whatever it's like you know
they got money [ __ ] them and it's
probably insured so business tell me to
hurry up you get drunk cuz you want some
dentists to make it appear yes is behind
me on a shelf Dennis is probably gonna
need to weigh in on this whole serial
killer issue so okay so where was I all
right
January 10th 1987 Barbara Agnew was the
next victim she was also a nurse she had
actually just been on a skiing trip in
Stratton Vermont it was a new guy she
was dating and she had gone up there to
ski with him and like with a couple of
friends and she was driving back home
now the strange thing about this okay so
what they ended up happening they found
her she had a green BMW and it was
parked at this rest stop on i-90 nan
Hartford Vermont now they couldn't
figure out why she had stopped at this
rest stop because like the weather the
night that she was driving home was like
really really shitty it was like a
snowstorm she was only ten miles from
home so they thought why you know why
pull over like when you only 10 miles
from if you had to go to the bathroom or
something like that you could probably
[ __ ] hold it for another ten miles
especially in weather as shitty as that
so they couldn't figure out like why she
had stopped at this rest stop but
apparently she did or someone lured her
in there I don't really know so they
left the car you know they find the car
at this rest stop the driver's side door
was open and there was blood on the
steering wheel now they didn't end up
finding her body for a couple of months
they found at the end of March 1987 near
an apple tree in Hartford she was still
wearing the ski bib she had worn on and
she still had the lift ticket like
attached to her
saying like from her ski trip and there
was still like blood all over the snow
even though like I said it had been like
three months at this point now she had
been stabbed multiple times just like
the other victims so they think what
ended up what happened was that she
pulled into the rest stop for like I
said whatever reason they still have no
idea like why she stopped there but it
looked like from the position of the
tires of the car like when they found it
it looked like what had happened was
that the killer had maybe blocked her in
and then she panicked and tried to back
out like again and get away from him and
then something like she got stuck in the
snow or something like that and then he
must have dragged her out of her car and
put her into his car or forced her loose
with a gun or whatever and then taken
her somewhere else and killed him like I
said cuz that was kind of like his MO
was he would go around and like he would
take them to another location you know
what I mean like either knock them out
or whatever it was that he was doing now
this was okay so the next thing that
happened now this was a big break like I
said they
still do not know who this guy is they
have not caught this guy April 6 1988
there was this woman named Jane barosky
now she was seven months pregnant she
had been at the County Fair in Keene New
Hampshire
now she was driving home that night and
you know she was pregnant so she said
you know I just got really really really
thirsty all of a sudden and I had to
stop so she stops at this closed grocery
store that was a vending machine in
front it was in Winchester New Hampshire
so she goes up she gets a coke out of
the machine and then she's sitting in
her car drinking it and then a car pulls
up next to her car and the guy like kind
of leans in the window and asks her if
the payphone works and then he opened
her door and started stabbing at her
like hitting at her and [ __ ] like that
then he starts saying this weird [ __ ]
about you hurt my girlfriend that's what
she said that he said and she's like no
I don't know who you are man I didn't
hurt your girl what are you talking
about and then he said jeez your car
have Massachusetts plates and she said
no they had New Hampshire plates then
she said the guy seemed like confused
about that and that it's almost like he
was gonna stop the attack um and that he
was I kind of backed off a little bit
and she's like well then I did something
kind of stupid because he had been like
struggling with me in the car and she
had like kicked her leg up and like
broken her windshield
and um so she said he kind of backed off
and she was like what the like what
about my windshield or what the [ __ ] did
you do to my windshield like you did
this for no reason like she got mad and
then he said something to the effect of
oh you're gonna be like that are you and
then he yeah and then he took out a
knife and started stabbing her now at
this point she was kind of out of the
car he stabbed her in the throat she
didn't know that until later she said
she opened her eyes and just saw her car
tire cuz so I guess she he stabbed her
and she fell and then she was like I
said she was pretty heavily pregnant so
she starts kind of trying to crawl or
like trying to run away
now the attacker comes up behind her and
just starts stab and stab and stab it
like in the back and she's like trying
to him to runnin and crawlin like a way
across the [ __ ] parking lot in this
grocery store he stabbed her 27 times
and I guess I mean she was bleeding
everywhere I guess he thought she was
dead or she was gonna die she said that
she remembered him like he got in his
car and like drove past her and he said
she said that he looked down at her like
and she was just laying there on the
ground bleeding to death and she said he
looked at me like you would look at a
bug you had just squashed she said he
just had this really really cold like he
didn't give a [ __ ] and um you know he
didn't care that I was pregnant he
didn't care any of that cuz she had said
you know don't don't hurt me I'm
pregnant all this other stuff so she
this woman she's a [ __ ] hero man she
stabbed 27 times in the throat and
everything she crawls back to her car
and she drove more than two miles in her
car even though he had almost severed
her thumb and her car was a manual
transmission like she could barely get
this [ __ ] started because her thumb
wouldn't work yeah and she's like she
was in such shock she's like oh it must
be broken like it but he was like
hanging off and she did this yeah baby
survived yeah man lucky doesn't I mean
her damn [ __ ] hormones man trying to
keep that baby alive well she did say
that she was like very she was like just
the whole time like trying to protect
her stomach mind over matter yes you
don't mind it don't matter she well and
I think some of it was shock do because
it's like well the interesting thing
about her and she said you know in
hindsight it seems really dumb because
when he started with the weird [ __ ]
about the license plate and you hurt my
girlfriend and all this sounds like he
was mentally ill yeah well maybe but
it's like it's like his cover story
yeah she's like if I hadn't got mad at
him and like yelled at him about hey you
broke my windshield or you made me break
my windshield it's like he might have
just taken off I don't know he would
have oh thank you thank you Larry
he's so you know he might have just kept
stabbing her anyway so I think she's I
mean you know she still has like that
survivor thing where she's like oh I
shouldn't have done that
of like made a man and almost somebody
he probably would have done it anyway um
he might have been psyching himself
making himself a false justification for
what he was doing yeah I definitely
think it was probably that so like I
said I mean I think he would have
stabbed her anyway so I don't think you
know I don't blame her for getting mad
at the dude it's like I would have to
she's like I probably shouldn't have
like been like hey [ __ ] or whatever
it's like you know but he probably would
have done it anyway so the crazy thing
about this so she's driving she wasn't
sure like she wasn't near her home but
she did remember she's like oh you know
I have like a friend of a friend that
lives a couple miles away I'm gonna go
there and have them call the ambulance
even though she didn't know the dude
that well so she drives there with a
[ __ ] half severed thumb and while
she's driving to this dude's house she
pulls up to a car like in front of her
and she realizes that it's it's in the
killer's car damn and so she she was
able to she said she was pretty sure if
you recognize her no well he was in
front of her okay so I guess he wasn't
really and it was like dark it was like
a country road or whatever now
so she um was able to see she that it
was a Jeep Wagoneer um she wasn't sure
of the year although it was 75 to 85 she
said it was like somewhere like a brown
or a gold type of color
she said she remember it was really
really dirty but that was kind of all
she remembered they did hypnotize her
later which I'll get into but so the
creepy thing is that so she gets to the
friend's house and she's up on the porch
and like I said the dude he knows her
but he's not like I think he was like a
friend of her boyfriend or something
like that so he comes to the door and
he's like flipping out and he's like oh
but she's like sit on the porch like
bleeding everywhere and while they're
sitting out there like you know getting
the phone and getting to call the police
and everything she sees the Wagoneer go
past the house and then make a u-turn in
the try past again if she's like that's
him that's him you know what I mean yeah
so yeah so [ __ ] scary dude didn't go
after him nah I guess not well I don't
know like I don't know she was able to
say cuz I don't know what condition she
was in at this point after that dude was
yeah what the [ __ ] holy crap so when she
finally gets to the hospital they find
out that she had a severed jugular vein
she
how could she still be alive she's still
alive two collapsed lungs because he had
stabbed her like in the back of the
front kidney laceration severed tendons
in her knees and her thumb the baby was
was okay had some issues she had to stay
in there for a little while but she
ended up being mostly okay they save her
thumb yeah as far as I know
thank you again Larry thank you again
thank you very much there yeah so it's
like there's interviews with her like on
a lot of documentaries about this it's
like holy crap I could just can't
[ __ ] believe that she lived through
that willpower I guess man she was
[ __ ] yeah so as I mentioned earlier
on the task force they had this guy
named John Philbin and he was not
it's weird cuz he wasn't like trained as
a profiler and he was trained as a
psychologist but he kind of like came
into profiling sort of sideways but
apparently according to everyone that
knew him he was really like you're
really good at it um he was very good at
getting into like one of his things was
he wanted to go to all the places where
the crimes have been committed he wanted
to know everything there was to know
about the victim about the killer he
would go to the place and like try to
get into the mindset of both the killer
and the victim and then try to figure
out like you know what the relationship
was what exactly had happened so what he
thought about this killer he's like I
think this is a person he didn't think
that any of these women cuz like I said
there was some [ __ ] going around because
a lot of the women were in nursing that
he was targeting missus specifically
either because like his mom was a nurse
and he hated her you know something like
that but John Feldmann seemed to think
he's like I don't think that he's
selecting these women as victims
particularly I think what he's doing is
pre selecting the murder sites what he
called it he's like this is like a
hunter like with a trapline he's like
there are these particular sites that he
will drive around and check and if there
is a woman there alone a vulnerable
woman then he will attack her so it's
like it's like he has a handful of sites
that he drives around in checks got a
lot of spare time on it like every yeah
like every now and then he thought that
it was more of that kind of thing
so um yes so he thought also this is
someone who you know even though the
savagery of the attacks like you know
the number of stabbings and stuff would
seem to suggest that this was more like
a you know more of an animalistic type
killer he did not think so he thought
this was a more organized killer someone
who drove around all the time like
looking for an opportunity someone who
got sexual gratification from the act of
stabbing from the act of killing more
than even though some of the victims
were sexually assaulted not all of them
were but he thought that it was someone
with like perhaps a blood fetish or
somebody who got like sexual charged
from from stabbing her from seeing blood
flowing he said this guy probably has a
job and a normal life
probably a job that allows him freedom
drive around like a truck driver or
delivery driver or something like that
he thought this dude was probably a
little bit older between 25 and 39
someone who harbored an intense
resentment toward his mother his mother
would have either abused or neglected
him and either that or had allowed the
father to abuse or neglect him and he
blamed the the woman this is somebody
who sees women as uppity someone who
thinks that that it's their fault that
they don't go along with the plans that
he has for them or if they just like go
about their lives without paying him any
attention he finds that offensive so he
said it was probably somebody like that
he said somebody who liked to maintain
control in all situations probably
someone who collected things like
baseball cards or you know had a
collection that type of thing probably
his job you know not only entailed
driving but also some kind of
record-keeping that is something that he
would have enjoyed like I said this is
very much a BTK type of yeah type of guy
is what and somebody like I said who
appeared normal
probably had a normal life he didn't
think I don't know if he thought that he
had like a long-term relationship but
somebody who you wouldn't really think
of as like a crazy for somebody who was
not mentally ill despite what Jane
barosky said about the weird [ __ ] that
he said to her about the license plate
and everything he said this is probably
not someone
who is mentally ill or would not come up
on anyone's radar as being like super
weird or anything like that so at this
point I mean Jane did remember like what
kind of car it was roughly what but
obviously a bunch of people had those
color g-wagen ears like in this large
area so finally they decide that they're
and she actually did give them a fairly
good description of what he looked like
she said that he was not a big dude she
said he was like about five seven five
eight not not fat or anything he was
just like maybe 150 160 pounds said he
had kind of a thin face that he had like
dirty blond hair and that it was all
kind of like swept back off his forehead
also said that he was wearing like kind
of a short sleeved like a casual type
shirt and dark blue pants but not jeans
she said they might have been khakis
like you know pleated khakis or
something like that so because she had
seen the back of the car but could not
remember what the license plate was John
Philbin the police profiler said maybe
we should hypnotize her and see if she
can remember anything better so they did
hypnotize her and she said that she
actually did end up remembering the
first three numbers of the license plate
which were six six two and she did
actually remember like some of those
they were jumbled that she that was live
was an N in there and she couldn't
really remember she said they were
definitely New Hampshire plates they
were white with green letters and she
said that in the corner it had a red
sticker she thought that it said 87 or
88 but they said well if it was red then
that probably meant that had expired in
1989 because I guess they were like
color coded but the fact that she
remembered that it was red like that
kind of you know gave them a clue as
well now they did actually run a search
of this vehicle with those numbers but
came up with over 300 possible matches
so as far as I know they were trying to
sort through all those and I don't know
if anything came out of this because
like I said this was you know 88 that
this happened 88 89
and as far as I know they didn't really
you know get anything from that even
though she did remember like all those
like I said they did have a composite
sketch and [ __ ] like that
now 1991 apparently there was a police
officer in Idaho who saw the composite
that had been drawn up from her you know
from her description and he thought that
it looked like somebody that had been in
the prison there and apparently he
called in a tip but I don't know if
anything ever came out of that now in
this case there have been three main
suspects they also talked about a few
other people in shadow of death the book
about it that I read so I'll get into
that in a minute - but the usually most
like the Wikipedia page and all that
they usually come up with these three
suspects now the first one of these is a
guy named Michael nicolau now this guy
was found apparently through a private
detective so this guy okay what ended up
happening so in 2001 this private
investigator gets contacted by the
mother of this woman named Michelle
Ashley who was a Vermont woman who had
been missing since 1988 with her two
kids so the private investigator
Limerick Rd she starts looking into this
disappearance now the woman who was
missing her common-law husband was
Michael nicolau now Michael nicolau was
a Vietnam vet he had been a helicopter
pilot now he was highly decorated he had
two Purple Hearts two silver stars two
Bronze Stars but in 1970 him and seven
of his comrades were were charged with
strafing civilians while on a
reconnaissance mission in the Mekong
Delta and also like some of the other
people in his unit some of the other
deeds in his unit also said that on at
least one occasion he had gone off to do
like hand-to-hand individual combat with
like other people in the villages like
he was going to hunt humans
quote-unquote so he was charged with
murder and attempted murder the charges
were eventually dropped but he was
discharged from the Army when he got
home he was apparently super pissed off
that the Army had supposedly mistreated
him and so he tried to sue them which
didn't was not successful so he also got
treatment from the VA for post-traumatic
stress disorder now he ended up going to
moving to Virginia and he opened a sex
shop called The Pleasure Chest which was
rated multiple times for engaging in
various illegal activities now while he
was in Virginia he met Michelle Ashley
who was the woman that went missing and
that's you know how this guy got
involved in everything so he moves to
Holyoke Massachusetts they had two two
kids now Michelle's family did not like
this guy they thought he was quiet they
thought he was a weirdo and what ended
up happening was that Michelle tried to
leave him with the two kids and
apparently he kind of started stalking
her after that and uh you know kind of
bothering her family members like trying
to find out where she was she actually
went back to him for a time but then we
told her family look I got to get the
[ __ ] out of here she was like afraid of
him so then after that she disappeared
so Michelle's mom like goes to the house
to find her and finds like she hasn't
heard from her for a few weeks she goes
to the house there's like spoiled food
in their refrigerator there's like all
this abandoned stuff like all her stuff
is still there and you know no one's in
the house so and everyone is gone so
everyone was like very weirded out about
that so the private investigator is able
to find Michael nicolau who has moved to
Georgia and had like an asteroids like
okay so what happened to Michelle and
your two kids he says the two kids are
fine Michelle was a [ __ ] and she ran off
with somebody else like a drug dealer or
something and I'm just like okay they're
a minor now killed her well yeah I'm
pretty sure what allegedly allegedly so
2005
if he marries again his wife a lien now
he ended up physically abusing her as
well and she tried to get away from him
so she ran to her sister's house in
Tampa Florida and he comes in to their
house he has a black suit and tie on
he's carrying a guitar case which is
full of guns he goes in there and leads
his wife Aileen and their stepdaughter
Taryn who was 22 into a bedroom killed
both of them and then killed himself hmm
so he checked out yeah I guess so now so
because this guy they think that he
lived in the Connecticut River Valley
area during the time of some of these
attacks they do think that maybe this
guy is a possible suspect although I
mean he did he lived close enough for
him to have done it but I think that he
was somewhere else like in a couple of
the cases so it's not like airtight but
he is a guy that comes up a lot you know
when they're talking about suspects for
this now a related dude now another
thing too that I should say about
Michael nicolau is that he's also kind
of brought up in some other unsolved you
know serial killing series as well like
the Colonial Parkway killer which we did
a show about before the route 29 stalker
the bridge Blue Ridge Parkway rapist
it's like there's so many of these scary
and they also think that he might be a
suspect or a person of interest in the
murder of Julie Ann Williams and Lolly
Wynans from the Shenandoah National Park
so like I said he's dead now so I guess
they'll never really find out unless
they can do DNA or whatever now the
second um you know and this guy's kind
of related a related suspect as well the
second guy that comes up a lot is the
student in Gary West over now this guy
was a paraplegic and in October of 1997
when he was then 46 years old he told
his uncle who was a sheriff's deputy
that in 1987 the heat that three of his
friends had picked him up and put him in
a van and that they had gone out to
party but they ended up abducting
murdering and dumping Barbara Agnew who
was the last victim of the valley killer
now there is also thought to be now this
guy died later did heal it died later
too but they thought that maybe one of
the friends that he was talking about
that had put him in this van if the
story is true or not I don't really know
but there is some speculation that one
of the friends that you know took him
out partying and put him in the van was
Michael nicolau because you know other
friends of his thought that name sounded
familiar so those two suspects are kind
of linked like I said I'm not sure that
guy's dead too so I'm not really sure
now there's another guy named Elbert
Tallman now this guy did actually kill
somebody they know about this in May
20th May 20th 1984 there was a 16 year
old girl named Heidi Martin she was out
jogging in Hartland Vermont and the
following day and she was abducted the
following day they found her raped and
stabbed in a swamp behind an elementary
school now Delbert Tallman who was 21 at
the time now he confessed
but then he recanted and then he was
acquitted now when Barbara Agnew was
murdered her body was found only a mile
away from where Heidi Martin's body had
been found so they brought Delbert
almond in for questioning and they did
note that he had previously lived in
several of the cities where some of the
other women had been murdered like Bello
Falls Windsor Vermont Clermont you know
so they kind of like sought to associate
him that way 1996 he was convicted of
two counts of lewd and lascivious
conduct with a child and he actually
ended up moving to Florida later on and
he was later arrested because he didn't
register with the sex offender registry
so he became a Florida man yeah well
they all come where was that that was 96
when he when he moved down here Oh Thank
You sidequest here Oh
showing us those flashbulbs happy fourth
love the show sorry it can be a picture
anymore but you know right oh yeah I
don't worry about it everybody had
everything these are tough all over yeah
everybody has situations man we're in
the [ __ ] apocalypse we're in the
apocalypse and I was born for this [ __ ]
I love talking about crazy Vietnam
veterans yeah that reminded me of Harold
Lee Ross my dad's cousin [ __ ] after I
got out of Korea
he got stationed uh with 101st John
three to seventh my dad said you know I
think my cousin [ __ ] Harold Lee was
in was in the three to seventh so I was
in a scalp attempt yeah and I said
really and he was like yeah he was in
the hundreds a scout is you should go
over there and go see him see we went
over there to go see him and he was a
scout in the hundred first but it wasn't
a three to seventh he was in the five Oh
deuce 5:02 and he went off on the
[ __ ] whole Vietnam thing he goes in
the [ __ ] closet and brings down a
couple of shoe boxes and then one of the
shoe boxes he had three Noxzema jars
filled with human ears I was just gonna
say is there human yeah cuz I had I had
heard that some people kept yeah he was
a [ __ ] ear taker and I was got a
thing to record the kills I guess man
[ __ ] the heads they were just show
fees and then he had they were all bad
though he had all the photographs of
everybody that had walked through the
damn ambush he was a team leader and a
recon platoon and they were setting
ambushes on these trails in between the
villages and the villagers were not
allowed to travel down those trails at
night because they were moving
ammunition and [ __ ] over bicycle and by
hand and the had ambushes set up and
anybody who walked along that damned
trail at night they just shot him up and
then go down there and see who it was
and next day they take photographs and
[ __ ] file hole reports and stuff then
they go back to the village and drag the
body out there and show the village
do not walk along those trails and I
like on stuff they warned of it punished
the villagers for doing it now they had
they had Arvind which it with them which
is you know Republic of South Vietnamese
army so you know I mean it's not just
Americans it was yeah South Vietnamese
army was with him too you know because
the South Vietnamese rice peasants in
some cases were helping the Communist
revolution you know but they had he had
pictures of all those [ __ ] people that
went through that damn ambush some of
them they had to take for the chain of
command some of them are private
pitchers you know just to keep track
it's [ __ ] wild yeah yeah and half of
more women yeah half of more women I
believe it yeah cuz women were carrying
all that ammunition it had bicycles with
[ __ ] aks hanging out the [ __ ]
handlebars girls and [ __ ] black
pajamas they did all kinds of weird [ __ ]
was it a good war no no we got involved
in somebody else's [ __ ] civil war
that's the [ __ ] problem I was a
soldier I do not believe in nation
buildings armies cannot build nations
they can only destroy nations all this
nation building one world government
America world police that ships [ __ ]
the fantasies of Richmond so you're out
there fighting rich man's war to build a
one-world government and you're not
gonna have any say in it does not help
the American people or the American the
American economy a little bit we make
money off that because all that money
that those government contracts make all
gets spent in McDonald's they get spent
and all these damn shopping malls so it
circulates you know I mean money doesn't
vanish it just he doesn't go to money
heaven [ __ ] circulates like blood you
know this blood money but they should
have been spending that [ __ ] on people
here well yeah you know and all this
stuff that we fought Iraq twice you know
I was in that first one or involved in
that first one that was a [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] waste of time
that was a waste of time going after
Saddam it was they should have left
Saddam in their little did we
No yeah that I mean but really the
bushes and [ __ ] it was about money more
anything else money in contracts
most things are theirs tell they're
telling the American people and the
world oh now all we have to do is get
rid of Saddam and [ __ ] man it'll be a
democracy over [ __ ] night no no those
people want nothing to do with that they
want theocracy they don't want democracy
we're always projecting our values on
these other people you know oh hey with
David they want a liberal democratic
[ __ ] república they don't know they
want as long that's what they want
that's their thing you know so it's just
[ __ ] stupid and that's one thing I
like about now I'm drunk I'm [ __ ]
ranting but just what it's about
what I like the direction that is going
now is all that [ __ ] is collapsing you
cannot be the world police you cannot
use military force to build other
nations you cannot regime-change other
countries that's all the Fannie's
fantasies of rich men that work behind
desks that doesn't happen
rich man fantasies and other guys and
the guys below them are taking it in a
fanny for the fantasies of these rich
men it's all the high-minded [ __ ]
all right now another suspect that some
of the task force liked but it's
interestingly this doesn't really get
mentioned a lot on a you know on other
sources like on Wikipedia or anything so
there's this guy now I will say that um
he did say the guy that wrote shadow of
death the book about this case he kind
of said now some of the names in there
were changed particularly like guys that
were suspects and they were never
formally charged with anything so it's
like you know to keep from getting sued
they like charged their names so what
hold on he's nice to say when he was in
Bosnia they were shooting the women and
children just for the fear of it yeah
it's called a high impact target and
[ __ ] we know all about that it may
not be a high-value target but if you're
in you know being it in a scout unit
dealing with snipers and [ __ ]
you want to [ __ ] engage when you
engage the enemy through sniping the
first person you kills the one is
supposed to give the most psychological
effect on the enemy which is a woman or
a child that immediately lets them know
that everybody's ass is on the [ __ ]
menu and it just sends them into a
[ __ ] frenzy go ahead because when
they see that you could you would kill
Oh a pretty young woman you don't I mean
or a child that means you don't give a
[ __ ] that you're there to kill everybody
and it usually [ __ ] routes them into
a panic they can't they can't [ __ ] or
reorganize and make any kind of coherent
military response because they're just
too terrorized
yeah yeah he knows exactly them time oh
yeah so this guy's so like I said I'm
not entirely sure if this is this dude's
real name or not but this was somebody
that they thought was interesting now I
will say that even though the profile of
this killer he did say that it was
likely not somebody with a mental
illness this guy I think probably had a
mental illness but he had some other
things that made him interesting this
was a guy named Richard Robert Bordeaux
now he was like this local eccentric he
lived in this really old like creepy
Victorian house that everybody around
there like called the haunted house and
everyone just kind of knew him as like
is the town weirdo like he would do [ __ ]
like he would come into diner and he
would order like two cups of coffee and
he had and this was an older dude he had
an imaginary friend named Bertram and he
ordered the coffee for Bertram and then
he would sit there and like talk to Bert
Bertram and like argue with him and
stuff like he was like for real there no
you know he had some problems he also
referred to himself as King Richard
changed his name Bordeaux he put like
the X on the end because he said he was
like French royalty even though
originally his last name didn't have an
X on the end which seems weird but
harmless however he was also well known
for harassing and stalking several women
around town there was one woke this one
woman she worked as like a waitress in
the diner name was Jenny Troy and this
dude he apparently she was the target of
like this year's long campaign of like
creepy letters
phone calls from this dude he loved that
woman he like talked to her like they
were like husband and wife already like
he was some of it wasn't like overtly
threatening it was just like really
creepy like he would just come in and go
so when are you gonna come over I have
an apple pie in the oven for you and I
was like and he just like kept bothering
her and kept bothering her and it's like
so she um you know she just tried to
like kind of play him off so I go you
know No thank you and I was like trying
to be polite and everything but
eventually it got to a point where she
was just like I need to call the cops
because it's like he won't [ __ ] leave
me alone so there was that whole thing
there was this other woman in town who
alleged that he had asked her out on a
date like they were gonna go out to
dinner but instead of doing that he just
drove her to a field took his pants off
and said hey I want to have sex with you
yeah he's living in his own [ __ ]
world there evidently and she was like
um yeah no thanks and now he didn't like
force it but he didn't really seem to
understand and he didn't know yeah he
like has some boundary issues big-time
he also another thing that he did was he
tried to on several occasions he tried
to join an all-female
aerobics class at the YMCA and stalked a
couple of the women that went to the
class and he became very hostile when he
was not allowed to join the class and he
said he was a black belt and he like
tried to punch the guy and that was
running the class and all this other
kind of stuff he was also seen dry
firing a rifle at buildings on at least
one occasion so this guy and he kind of
lived in the area he had like of some
like I said he did have a mental illness
obviously but he did have some other
personality attributes that made him
kind of interesting for somebody that
would do this type of thing there were a
couple of other persons of interest that
they looked at as well like I said I'm
not sure if these are their real names
these are just the names that he used in
the book and like I said he's you know
for legal reasons he might have changed
some of the names he didn't really say
when he did that one of the guys was
this really angry like roided-out dude
called crazy eddie strug Nell he
actually had an alibi for the time of
one of the murders but some of the
others just because he was very
I think even when the cops came to
question him he like [ __ ] wing the
[ __ ] tire at their heads or something
like that so he was like a little um you
know he wasn't taking on edge he was
taking that [ __ ] juice taking that
those steroids yeah I definitely in his
mood stabiliser [ __ ] testosterone
level of a fourteen-year-old boy yeah
testosterone the drugs the law anger
yeah I mean it's only good they said the
cops like went out like two I think he
worked at like a junkyard mechanics
place or something and they went out
there to like question about one of the
particular murders and they said that he
immediately just got really really
hostile and you just like [ __ ] like I
think they said he picked up like a like
a heavy tire or something and just like
slung it when I'm having it that's yeah
clearly now like I said they they were
kind of interested in this dude but they
were like um he did have a solid alibi
for for one of the times of the crime so
maybe not there was also this other guy
in the book he was called Jeffrey Miller
now this guy was in the Navy he was
stationed in the Philippines but he was
home during the time that the murders
were going on like he was on labor
whatever now he was interestingly enough
was seen jogging near Linda Moore's
house Linda Moore was the one that was
stabbed to death in her house now he was
seen jogging by her house a few hours
before she was killed and a few hours
after she was killed which they thought
was a little weird also um when they
asked him about the murder he seemed to
act
he acted really strange like he didn't
care about it but then like after he had
gone back to the Philippines he wrote a
letter back to one of his family members
and he was like really interested like
hey what's going on with that even
though he hadn't seemed to care about it
while I was there he also was given a
polygraph and when they asked him
questions about if he knew anything
about you know did you hurt Linda more
did you do this and that the other um it
implied that he was being deceptive um
so they're not real sure and when they
took when they confronted him about that
afterward he's like huh that's
interesting well your machine must not
work or something like that like he said
something along those lines so they
thought that was a little bit fishy they
also thought that
it he looked a lot like the dude that
had been seen around Linda's Linda
Moore's house by witnesses that they you
know somebody they thought was like
lurking around now this guy was like
pretty young he was only 19 at the time
that Linda Moore was killed so like I
said I'm not sure if Jeffrey Miller's
his real name that's just the name they
gave him in the book I'm assuming that's
not his real name because I don't think
he was ever charged with anything now in
this particular series like I said those
are the canonical ones the only one
that's a little bit questionable like I
said sometimes they don't you know group
the Linda Moore and murder in with it
just because you know she was killed in
her house where the other ones were you
know killed and pulled out of their cars
and killed elsewhere you know or were
killed hitchhiking or whatever but like
I said the profiler did seem to think
that that was part of the series just
because of the mo was similar even
though she wasn't taken somewhere else
and dumped now there were some other
murders that took place in this area
that may or may not be part of the same
series now one of these goes all the way
back to 1968 and I actually heard about
this girl I think in one of in phases
villain - maybe this was a Joanne Dunham
now she was killed on June 11th 1968
sexually assaulted and strangled in
Charlestown New Hampshire there was also
an older woman I believe she was 76
years old named Sylvia gray now she was
killed
October 5th 1982 she was stabbed and
bludgeoned to death in a wooded area of
Plainfield New Hampshire she had been
missing reported missing the day before
so she was found like not far from her
house there was also a woman named Sarah
hunter now September 19 1986 her car was
found abandoned at a gas station on
route 7 a and two months later they
found her body she had been strangled to
death
there was a actually a male victim
Stephen Hill June 20th 1986 he was last
seen picking up his paycheck in Lebanon
New Hampshire and then they found his
remains on July 15th with multiple stab
wounds and they found his body in
Hartland Vermont which was across the
river from where Sylvia Gray's body was
found four years before there was also a
victim named Carrie Moss this was July
25th 1989 she left her home in New
Boston New Hampshire to visit friends in
Goffstown and disappeared
they found her skeletal remains
years later July 25th 1991 could not
determine cause of death so like I said
because these all kind of occurred in
the same area and some of them like I
said some were strangled so maybe that
was somebody different but the stabbing
ones is probably because that seems to
be this signature the signature of this
particular killer as I said this dude
has yet to be caught and they're not
sure entirely which ones of these crimes
are part of the same series although I
would assume the ones that are stabbed
like I said particularly ones that are
stabbed in the throat the you know the
pattern of that he described it as like
a flat V pattern like I'm stabbing like
on the abdomen because several of the
victims had that as well and we're
usually taken out of their cars or taken
out of a particular area and then dumped
somewhere else so they think those are
all the same killer and we still do not
know whom the [ __ ] this dude is so I'm
actually gonna I'm gonna take a break
right now so you entertain them all
right moment and then when I come back
we're gonna talk about the red head
murders you can entertain future yeah
okay well I'm just gonna back around you
back around you yeah they're talking
about you know guys have had hard
service lights and [ __ ] like that
but you got a look at you got a look at
the records of how things go
most guys shake that [ __ ] back pretty
quick
a couple years a lot of guys depending
on what kind of service they were in
what the unit was like they miss it they
want to go back it's it's when you take
young guys and you put them in a high
[ __ ] adrenaline situation they adapt
to that it's hormonal II supported in
men when you get a bunch of men together
doing that [ __ ] they kind of bond in a
way that just can't happen anywhere else
you know in any other situation they
become kind of like family they may not
even like each other but they're like
catch a bullet for each other it's that
and this phenomenon goes way back to the
[ __ ] Greeks and the Romans you know
they were like that so even though dude
might have a hard time he keeps thinking
of
a good a good example is the guys from
World War two a lot of those guys saw
[ __ ] heavy action especially against
the Japanese out on those islands and
they spent the rest of their lives and
and it they actually didn't live long a
lot of them but they spent the rest of
their lives wanting to go back but they
couldn't and the military had been
trimmed down to nothing so they just
kind of drank themselves into a [ __ ]
into a stupor - because they're so
[ __ ] amped up and everything's so
boring - in order to kind of give
himself some anesthesia they were
constantly drinking they would drink put
on Hawaiian shirts listen to [ __ ]
Tiki music and [ __ ] you know I mean it
was just they were just that was just
that generation then they died behind
the wheel because they were drinking too
much joining motorcycle gangs and stuff
this is just the way that is you know
what they do now is a lot different a
lot of these guys that [ __ ] had some
which I agree with what they're doing
now a lot of dudes that get wounded or
saw a lot of their friends get killed
and they had a real [ __ ] adventurous
[ __ ] tour really the army doesn't
want to get out they'll keep them in
there for the rest of their lives
because nobody's gonna understand them
when they get out so they keep them
around and that and then the the mental
health actually is a lot better because
they're where they need to be to be
they'll let them go for a few months or
a year to kind of recharge and then
they'll bring them back in and but
that's how they're doing it now they
really don't let them out I guess you
could say they let them out but they
don't kick them out like the ants -
that's probably they let them stay in
the unit name Oh mow lawns and teach and
train and they may not go to action but
you know I mean they're still part of
the unit the unit [ __ ] let's um let
some work there which that's the way it
should be well the thing about it - and
I think this happened a lot with the you
know the Vietnam veterans in particular
just because that was such a shitty war
it was an unpopular war you know and
they kind of got treated like crap when
they got back and so I do kind of feel
like another thing too is that a lot of
dudes it's
very much in the mail mentality to like
not ask for help or to not you know they
don't want to be seen as like weak I
guess you can't help them right you
can't help them I mean who's gonna help
them with the ship they had to do the
ship they saw like a lot of Lube and
they don't want to they don't want to
get like psychiatric help they don't
want it because it seems like well what
are they gonna do for ya they can't do
anything for them
dope him up that's not gonna help them
yeah they just keep them in the unit
keep him working keep him around people
that understand them and that's the best
thing to do with them that's what
they're doing now the guys who got the
worst though you know Vietnam you know
that the American Vietnam veteran you
know they had it rough but who had it
worse than that war World War one
veteran's because when they went home
people didn't even know what World War 1
front life was like they had no idea
what was going on there
holy crap and that was like [ __ ] no
gym no media no now cuz remember we saw
that yeah documentaries them with all
the footage in World War one and [ __ ]
like that that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
horrifying and they basically didn't
fight they sat there and those trenches
got rained on it got shelled constantly
yeah and they just got [ __ ] killed so
a lot of pent up tension and waiting and
waiting and waiting and waiting big show
what that must have been like they just
sit there yeah just wait it's like you
don't know if you could die like at any
second yeah and ever [ __ ] relax and
then never actually got to fight to blow
any that steam off right so and then
they went home and nobody even knew
where they were yeah you know the
society at large
came back you know you back come on
nobody understood it back to normal
and the veterans that survivors said
that they had that they had been
transformed into an entirely different
species of man and then the average
person had no idea how to deal with them
so but yeah I mean that was the that was
the very beginnings of mechanized
warfare and the generals and the systems
that were running it had no idea of any
the repercussions and they didn't know
how to manage it most of those dudes
should have never been released back
into society yeah they should have
stayed in the army
trainers and they should have [ __ ]
taken care of it basically for the rest
of their lives how to run an army
because if they want to go home they can
yeah and but usually typically what they
do is they'll go home for a few a few
years and they'll get totally
disenchanted with the [ __ ] and then II
want to go back they want to go back to
the army where guys understand them yeah
and that's really how they should have
done it yeah
but they figured that out now armies are
good at that now well like you said it's
kind of a better yes yeah because you
could stay around people that you know
can still relate to you they did they've
been through the same [ __ ] that you've
been through yeah and those dudes are a
end up you know they're older than all
the other soldiers but they still got
all their status they sit there they
tell all their stories and they're still
involved in everything and they're still
needed their skills are still needed you
put that guy on the street what's he
gonna do go work at [ __ ] McDonald's
he's gonna go [ __ ] work at a at a at
a [ __ ] TGI Fridays and [ __ ]
what's he gonna do may not want to make
that guy a cop you know ya know I don't
think any good will come yeah you may
not want to do that so you want to keep
those guys in the military system or the
government system contractors and stuff
yeah that's the world they were made in
and that's why I should stay yeah yeah
all right so all right so let's talk
about this other case of possible on
cots Erica now there are some people
that speculate that these redhead
murders that they also call the the
killer the Bible Belt strangler that
maybe this is not all one person like
every single case that they're talking
about like maybe this is multiple
killers which is possible but I
definitely do think that some of these
are linked the scariest thing about this
I was like what [ __ ] watching a video
about this earlier is that you know
we've talked about a couple of other
sort of highway killers like other shows
you ticks a Texas killing field you got
your Colonial Parkway killer you got
like all these you know um killers that
like prey on people that are like on the
roads hitchhikers like sex workers that
you know work at truck stops or whatever
and it's so widespread that I think it's
the FBI they even have like the highway
killings like initiative or something
like that and there's like [ __ ] 700
something cases on that [ __ ] thing of
like you know women it's almost always
women that you know they just find their
bodies on the side of the road and
they're presuming that it's you know
truck drivers you know I don't think
anybody's arguing that it's just one
dude doing it but it's like there's at
least a handful of serial killers that
are you know truck drivers are in a
truck driving adjacent capacity that are
basically just going around picking
women up and killing them and dumping
them on the side of the road which is
what happened in this right now the
redhead murders they usually get put
together because all the victims you
know as the name suggests they all had
red hair strawberry blonde Auburn
something like that which you know
redheaded miss is fairly rare so I guess
if you do see like a lot of victims that
have the same color hair you got to
think that maybe there is some kind of
like another matter you're gonna go make
another train car right yeah might as
well fill it up while you're in there
cuz I'm gonna be I'm gonna be empty in a
little while alright so the redhead
murders spans several states Tennessee
Arkansas Kentucky Mississippi
Pennsylvania and West Virginia there are
also a couple of other states thrown in
there but like I said we don't know the
canonical you know number of cases
usually it's considered that the victims
are somewhere between 6 and 11 because
like I said some of the bodies you know
they didn't find them till much later
they weren't sure entirely you know how
they were killed so they don't know if
there's like a pattern there so this guy
like I said is also called sometimes the
Bible Belt strangler just because of the
part of the us that he is targeting it
is thought that these killings occurred
between October of 1978 and sometime in
the 1980s although there are some later
they think there's one case that I'm in
particular that happened in 1992 that
they think might be part of that same
series now these are women that were
generally you know sex workers or they
were hitchhiking or something like
that were usually found you know
alongside major highways are right off
of a major highway almost all of them
had red or reddish hair in cases where
their hair color could be determined
so these like I said they don't know how
many people are responsible for these
somewhere between 6 and 11 victims are
usually now the sad thing about this too
is that a whole bunch of the victims of
this are still unidentified a couple of
them actually almost all of them were
unidentified a few of them were
identified finally in 2018 but a lot of
them are still not known nowadays which
is very very sad so the first one in the
series was or at least the you know the
first one in the canonical series this
was an unidentified woman she's usually
called Wetzel County Jane Doe now this
was a white female she was found naked
along side route 2 15 near Littleton
Wetzel County West Virginia
she was found February 13th 1983 now she
was actually found by a pet like a an
older couple they were out for a drive
and they saw something on the side of
the road that they thought was a
mannequin and like I've said many times
if you think it's a mannequin on the
side of the road it's not a mannequin
because they always think it's a
mannequin and it's not what has it ever
been a mannequin it's always a dead body
so in this case it was a dead body now
they thought that this woman had been
dead for about two days but they thought
that her body had only just recently
been dumped there because it was laying
there and she was naked and it had been
snowing but there was no snow on the
body only underneath the body so they
thought that the body had been dumped
there like nothing you know very soon
you before like the the old people like
found her there because there was no
snow on the body so they also found like
some footprints around there and some
tire tracks I don't know if they ever
figure out because it was in the snow I
don't know if they ever figured out like
you know what car the tire tracks were
farm or anything like that
like I said they thought that she had
been dead for about two days
it didn't look like she had been
sexually assaulted like I said it's it's
kind of hard to tell in these cases and
like I said if she had she been a sex
worker I guess there was really no way
to determine that with any certainty the
cause of death was not officially
determined although they speculated that
she may have been strangled or perhaps
suffocated now this woman was on the
older like you know considering like how
the later victims would usually be
younger women this one was a little bit
on the older side like as far as the
victims went they thought she was maybe
between 35 and 45 years old she had a
burn hair five foot six inches about 135
pounds they thought her eyes might have
been brown although because of the
decomposition they could not tell she
had um two scars one from a c-section
and she also had one small scar on one
of her index fingers they did not think
that she was homeless
mainly because she was fairly well
groomed like it looked like she had just
you know shaved her legs and shaved her
underarms and stuff like that which
meant that she had someplace to stay she
had access to you know toiletries and
things like that so they thought that
she was not a homeless person although
she very well could have been a sex
worker she was living at a hotel or
something like that um now a dude was
seen lurking around the area where her
body was found shortly before the body
was found this dude oh I hear the ER the
ice rattling there you go
here thank you very much vodka apple
juice juice now silver tequila and rock
star to it that rock star is [ __ ]
good I like it well that's good cuz it's
way cheaper than the [ __ ] yeah so
kind of tastes like a Brazilian drink
called quad or not yeah you found that
boy yeah doesn't want enough I like it
yeah Saul Hernandez says there are
shirts that say it's never a mannequin
from a see that's what I always say
because how many cases have I written
about where the people were like oh I
thought it was a mannequin on the side
of her
never a man again that's because women
love true-crime [ __ ] that's why I don't
know why we did what we do so the dude
that was seen lurking around where
Wetzel County Jane Doe was found was
described as a middle-aged white male
with a Pookie with who's here oh my
goodness
honey she comes busting on anyone I just
woke up she's been sleeping all day
hey Pookie how you doing did you get out
from under the bath mat you're being
such a good girl yes you've been
sleeping all day yeah that's what Katy's
do I guess
so is your uh standard-issue middle-aged
white male about five standard issue
well I'm just saying that's that's
usually like serial killers usually
height approximately 5 foot 10 inches
about 185 to 200 pounds so they thought
that maybe the student kind of been seen
lurking around the area so maybe this
was the dude that had dumped it they're
not entirely sure now
this victim it later came out witnesses
thought they had maybe seen her or
someone fitting her description in
Wheeling West Virginia now they had seen
her in a bar they didn't know she was a
customer if she was working there this
has actually not been confirmed like I
said this woman is just known as Wetzel
County Jane Doe there are pictures of
her online if you look it up and she has
as yet not been identified
now the next canonical victim of the
redhead murders was Lisa Nichols now she
was 28 years old it was also known as
Lisa Jarvis she's like a different last
name she was found on September 16 1984
along Interstate 40 near West Memphis
Arkansas good old West Memphis we just
did a show about West Memphis three a
couple weeks ago she was from West
Virginia now she was actually not
identified for a while she was the sad
thing about this like I said a lot of
the victims in this series were not
identified I think because a lot of them
were sex workers or were estranged from
their families so they were never
reported missing so she actually wasn't
identified for about a year but then
finally they did identify her now she
was strangled she was she was naked
except for a sweater that's all she was
wearing as a sweater
she had strawberry blonde hair at the
time because like I said not all of
these had naturally red hair so it was
dyed or some of it was like highlighted
or something like that so they're not
sure if this is just a guy that's
targeting redheaded women particularly
but it's not just like you know natural
redheads it's just anybody with any kind
of red hair so she had strawberry blonde
hair she had actually been staying with
an older couple in Florida and they were
the ones who actually like you know
ended up seeing the photo and came up to
identify her as Lisa Nichols they
thought that she may have been murdered
after leaving a truck stop along the
highway she may have been attempting to
hitchhike the next victim also
unidentified a Campbell County Jane Doe
found January 1st 1985 found near
Jellico Tennessee on Interstate 75 she
had been killed three days before her
body was found on or around December
30th 1984 already a very decomposed her
body was she was white had short red
hair which was kind of curly she was
probably between 17 and 25 though she
could have been as old as 30 years old
she was actually found fully dressed
unlike a couple of the other victims she
had its hand pull over like a top
sweater she had a shirt and jeans she
had green or hazel eyes they're not
entirely sure because like I said she
was kind of decomposed also had freckles
and some scars and burn marks on her
body and she was found to be two to two
and a half to five months pregnant cause
of death could not be determined because
of the decomposition
she had interestingly and I'm surprised
that this fact has not made it easier to
identify her because even though she was
quite young I mean she was under 30
years old she had a partial denture like
on her upper jaw and it was holding in
two of her teeth you know what I mean
like so she had presumably lost to like
her two front teeth at some point and
she had like a denture that just had
like
- so like I said she's very young but
she's still had a denture she was quite
small 5 foot 1 to 5 foot for about 110
115 pounds although they're not real
sure about that weight cuz like I said
she was very much guys
yeah now this woman actually was
identified much later in 2018 like I
said for a while she was just Campbell
County Jane Doe 2018 they announced that
they had identified this woman Teena
Marie
McKenney farmer she was originally from
Indiana she was about 21 years old at
the time of her death was last seen
Indianapolis Indiana accompanied by a
trucker and they were supposedly going
to Kentucky whether this trucker was the
one that killed her if she ended up like
getting a ride with someone else that
killed her they're not entirely sure she
did have one daughter she had
disappeared in 1984 she was reported
missing but for whatever reason the
authorities in Indiana never entered her
into a national database I'm not really
sure why because I guess at the time
Indiana didn't have a law where you had
to do that I'm not really sure what the
law is now but hopefully it's not that I
mean because you would think that would
be the first thing you would do right
it's like [ __ ] national database
because you know so it'd be easier to
find them but they did actually end up
they did actually end up buying her
later on and in her case they actually
did end up finding the killer as well
but I will get into that in a little bit
well actually maybe I'll get into that
now so because this just happened
recently
so 2019 they actually ended up getting
DNA and they found out that this
particular woman had been killed by a
dude named Jerry Leon Jones now if he's
dead he died in prison in 2015 he had
been known as a kidnapper before he had
been convicted in 1987 of aggravated
kidnapping and assault what ended up
happening with him was that he had
attacked this woman who was also a
redhead named Linda shocky
I guess it's how you pronounce her last
name he picked her up in Tennessee
County this was two months after Tina
farmer had disappeared now he picked up
Linda's Shecky and raped her and left
her on the side of the road he thought
she was dead like he left her in a
culvert somewhere but she lived she got
strangled and she got like tied up and
everything and he like left her on the
side of i-40 and but she ended up
surviving and she you know ended up
testifying against him because she
remembered him and recognized him she
had actually been just like Tina farmer
was the the dude had like torn off a
piece of her shirt and like strangled
her with it like tied around her neck
and strangled her with it and he left
her in a storm drain so like I said she
also had red hair but so they determined
through DNA that this dude Jerry Lee
Jones had also killed Tina farmer you
know what I mean so whether he was
responsible for the red head murders up
to that point I'm not entirely sure
because they didn't identify him till
later on but so that's why he's like
considered one of the main suspect
because he did attack a redheaded woman
Linda Jackie who actually ended up
surviving even though he had left her
for dead and they're sure that he had
killed Tina farmer who was one of the
canonical redhead murders cases okay so
let's see so there was another
unidentified victim found in Campbell
County also now she was found on April
3rd 1985 they're not sure if she was a
redhead or not because like I said you
know their remains were too decomposed
to determine they think that she died
between 1981 and 1984 this was a younger
girl they think she was maybe 15 at most
maybe between 9 and 15 whereas the other
victims were all a little bit older like
in their 20s or 30s now she was found
off of big wheel Gap Road four miles
southwest of Jellico near where one of
the other victims had been found off of
interstate 75 near a strip mine they
also don't know the cause of death on
this one because she was too decomposed
she had been dead for for somewhere
between one and four years when they
found her body so they couldn't
determine I think she was just bones
honestly they just found a skull and
like 32 other bones so they weren't
entirely sure how she died they
do a facial reconstruction like I said
if you want to its second Campbell
County Jane Doe you can look that up
they did a facial a very good facial
reconstruction of her they said the only
the only other distinguishing thing she
had like a necklace and a bracelet that
were made of like buttons you know like
from shirt buttons like had been made
out of that they also found a pair of
size 5 boots near the scene which may or
may not have belonged to her but they
weren't sure what her hair color was
what her eye color wasn't anything like
that because like I said she was just
bones now this other victim was also a
skeleton
this was the Cheatham County Jane Doe
she was found on March 31st 1985 no she
did have red hair she had maybe died
three to five months before again cause
of death unable to be determined most of
the time like in these cases when they
say that they're unable to determine
cause of death it's usually
strangulation or suffocation because if
they if they were stabbed they can
usually tell that even from bones but
strangulation and suffocation they can't
tell that from bones so I think they
usually will just say that it's
undetermined like if they just un
skeletonized remains just bones yeah you
know it's because I think like you can
tell sometimes from the hyoid bone bone
like if it's if it's messed up or it's
missing or something they assume
strangulation but I don't think they
want to come out and say that if they're
not entirely sure so they found this
woman on the side of Interstate 24 she
was also fully dressed she had underwear
pants shirt sweater the whole nine yards
she was a white girl between five foot
five foot two they weren't sure what her
weight was she had some like her teeth
were like kind of overlapped with one
another like crowded in her mouth they
think she was between 31 and 48 years
old at the time of death again this
woman is also unidentified they found
another woman who at the time was I
believe she was just called Knox County
Jane Doe now this woman there pretty
sure died by suffocation they found her
inside a refrigerator on the side of the
road it was a white admirable
refrigerator this was in gray Knox
County Kentucky
April 1st 1985 alongside that route 25
the refrigerator had a decal on the feel
like a sticker on the front that said
superwoman on it hmm but they found her
body inside of it she had been dead for
a few days she was found naked um they
did find she had all she had on was a
necklace well she had two necklaces they
were both gold one was had a heart on it
and one was like a gold like a eagle she
also had two pairs of socks one white
and one white with green and yellow
stripes on them they thought that this
woman may have been soliciting a ride to
North Carolina over CB now this woman
she had like a whole bunch of moles on
the side of her neck on her ankle below
each breast she also had one of her
upper incisors was stained yellow she
had some other scars I believe she also
had a c-section scar she had red hair
also light brown eyes you know her hair
was actually really long now she was
between 2535 years old approximately
four foot nine to four foot eleven so
again if they're small woman sounds like
a lot lizard yeah it may have been now
this woman was actually for a time was
not identified she was finally
identified in October first on October
1st 2018 this woman had been positively
identified as SB Regina black pilgrim
they actually ended up doing I think
what ended up happening was that her
sister had seen the description of her
like on a web form or something like
that and gave DNA and they were able to
match it to her so that is who that
woman was prostitute um I don't think so
they never said that um she was just
hitchhiking okay um so yes so tell you
one thing he's into little women these
are all very small women most of them
are very small yes and like I said yeah
he could handle him he may not be very
big him so maybe he's not very big
either
cuz like it you like you said he's going
after because more women yes so this
particular woman she had four children
and then she actually had had just had a
baby six weeks private previously and
when she disappeared so she actually had
a baby at home
when she disappeared so she had five
kids I believe what is she doing hang
around with truckers who knows like I
said sums up there well like I said you
all they know was that she was trying to
find a ride somewhere that they that's
what they think that she was like on the
CB like looking for a ride someplace to
North Carolina eg North Carolina that's
where she lived so I don't yes so I
don't know like I said I'm not you know
victim-blaming like that no I'm just
saying there's more to it than there's
more to it than what they're saying I
think this guy's going for a lot lizards
it's it's totally possible I drove a
they definitely do think it's a trucker
and like I said the one guy that that
killed one of the women on there that
they know of tina farmer he definitely
was a trucker all right and that's the
scary thing I'm not saying like truckers
or serial killers or anything like that
but it's a popular but it is a popular
job for serial kid because you are on
your own like no one's watching you you
can like travel over state lines easily
like nobody suspects any I think it's
more of a thing of evolution yeah yeah
if you are a serial killer and you
happen to be a trucker you will be
operating for a lot longer than a guy
who is not a serial killer
yeah are you see me not true not I'm not
a truck driver and you're a serial
killer because it's kind of a lifestyle
that kind of fits in with that yeah
you're constantly moving you're moving
from one legal jurisdiction to another
yeah so every time you kill somebody and
dump a body it's a different police
station that's doing the damn invest
exactly and most of our little podunk
police station yeah and they don't know
who this woman is she's not from that
and I think that's exactly what happened
and they're like we don't really know
who this is and she's some kind of lot
lizard or something you know I mean
she's not one of ours
yeah so that's the mentality and I
definitely think that's what's happening
with like all the murders that take
place at the Texas killing field and
stuff like that because that's
definitely not one serial killer that's
more than yeah and I think it's dudes
that are like driving through the area
you know yeah and it's not like the cops
don't give a [ __ ] it's just that man
every [ __ ] day thousands and
thousands of [ __ ] truck drivers might
go down that damn [ __ ] Road yep
people don't realize the United States
is not powered by railroads it's powered
by truckers yeah truckers are [ __ ]
move in all this all these supplies
here without them there's just there's
just no they're the circulatory system
that the United States so all you need
is one bad when he could he can rack up
a lot of bodies yeah because he's he can
hide within the mass of all those
suckers making their deliveries you know
what I mean even like I said like I'm
saying before like how the FBI is like
the highway killings initiative and they
have like 750 [ __ ] murders on there
of just like women that were dumped on
the side of the road by highways and
[ __ ] and you know even if it was just
like for example I mean this is a big
country there's a lot of truck drivers
even if it were just say five truck
drivers there were serial killers five
truck driving serial killers can do a
lot of damage yeah and go on for a long
time with any leave bodies all over the
dad place so they're hard to figure out
yeah
hard to figure out where it's all coming
from maybe impossible impossible and
especially if they're targeting women
that are you know that are being lots of
guys that are seeing lots of guys that
are you know wandering around somewhere
where they are not originally from like
where their family is not what their
family doesn't know where they are like
investigative techniques their main
weapon is elimination yeah you have to
eliminate suspects well in a situation
like that you can't eliminate any of
them so you got thousands of them yeah I
can't find it
cuz it could be anybody yep so I know
it's scary yeah it's definitely scary
yeah don't be a lot lizard don't jump in
there with him dude well yeah it's like
I I think nobody like nobody [ __ ] HIV
wants to be a lot lizard and nobody
wants to be a [ __ ] attract because
everybody knows that I feel like in the
60s and 70s everyone's kind of
freewheeling and like let's just
hitchhike here and there and like I said
most of them short drivers are good
dudes yeah ninety-nine times out of a
hundred nothing happens so you didn't
hear about it it was just like you know
the few times that something horrible
did happen you just may wanna if you're
gonna get in a truck with a [ __ ]
driver you may want to [ __ ] get in
one it's got some get into get into a
truck where that the driver has has
[ __ ] recommendations but how would you
know I mean I mean how he's scared to
get in with a [ __ ] uber driver because
you don't know he's not really no crazy
hey you don't know anybody that's what I
mean you can't go through your whole
life not trusting anybody ever but it's
like have a means of defense if you ask
me yeah I mean you know especially if
you know that you're gonna have to be at
the mercy of somebody like I said
whether it's a whether you had a
hitchhike or whether it's uber driver
probably they don't only my only advice
is to you ladies out there is to follow
your instincts follow your gut instincts
you can tell when a dude seems a little
bit wrong all right then don't feel
stupid right just looking again
sometimes you just get a good feeling
when you meet somebody you know I mean
it's because a lot of things kind of
[ __ ] the lineup nothing is out of
[ __ ] place so you know I mean you eat
a lot of times these [ __ ] girls get
into these positions because they're
desperate they just want drug money yeah
that I mean well yeah they got to turn
this trick to get drug money they'll get
in the car with a dude even if he's
[ __ ] yeah because I get a man like I
said that's a lot of times what's
happening you know yeah I mean it's
always better like I said it's it's easy
to say you know it's always better to
err on the side of caution but you know
if that's your only source of income
then you're gonna have to put yourself
into like some shitty situations it
really someone I can talk about is
[ __ ] Gary Ridgway I could look at
Gary Ridgway tell you that [ __ ]
this comeback well yeah I mean they
don't all look like that though cream
look like yeah but that is a creepy yeah
all right he's not the normal all right
I think one that might fool me would
have been [ __ ] Rader yeah
because he seems so unassuming yeah and
he showed up in a uniform yeah with this
damn you know I mean I'm working for the
state and he's a tight-ass again he's a
tight-ass yeah you know I mean see how
I'm saying that tight-ass you saying
that like you're into it yeah yeah maybe
you love to say that it's what the [ __ ]
no I'm just saying he seems uptight yeah
and you don't as expect that's an
uptight guy to be a [ __ ] serial
killer I do I don't
[Laughter]
I would think more just a creep yeah no
I mean I assume everyone's a serial
killer until they prove otherwise
dude comes at you like he was [ __ ]
official yeah I mean yeah and that's
that that would take you off guard
excuse me ma'am do you know how long
your grass is Yeah right yeah he's like
right
I know he's like he's back there he's
probably like oh you wanna go get him I
want to be on you guys you guys can't
see it but Pookie is laying on her back
just like right over there comes charlie
she's looking at this upset Charlie yeah
Charlie tom-toms a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's nothing tight about my ass I was
just doing what I had to do you know and
being an upstanding citizen I'm making
sure that the grass is all the right
size and everyone's dogs were behaving
yeah making sure everybody's going to
church but you know I had that x-factor
sometimes I'd see one and I'd kind of
make a start a project and I'd watch her
and it and [ __ ] had to be mine yeah I
took her to church I took him to church
I took photographs of them put my
pantyhose on man's got a dude he's gotta
do it's art it's just art artwork okay
so the next victim was found on April
14th 1985 this is known as Green County
Jane Doe located in Greenville Tennessee
now she had been stabbed and also
possibly blunt for blunt-force trauma so
that's a little bit different because I
think the other ones were strangled
separated what do you say she was
visibly she was visibly upset yeah for
some reason like of all the [ __ ] that he
did when I when I watched his trial you
know and him giving the statement itself
that infuriated me well she got upset
you know more than and it's just I don't
know that it's just like that that just
like maybe of all the [ __ ] that he was
and I was like getting madder and madder
but then when he said that I was just
like it's like if I could just like
reach through the TV and punch you in
the dick right now I told her I was
gonna have to kill her and of course you
know she got upset yeah I was like oh
weird [ __ ] man you think she made me get
upset I wonder why that happened why do
you think she got upset
Dennis it's not that you're gonna kill
her you got that yeah what a [ __ ] why'd
she get so upset why he so upset he was
trying to be all [ __ ] sensitive about
you know I told her I was gonna kill her
you know she got upset feeling
physically [ __ ] upset so I saw I gave
her some some calm her down a little bit
yeah in that weird that's not I mean
that like that [ __ ] just infuriated me
it just infuriated me so I called her
down a little bit man I killed her I'm
like oh you don't want you don't want me
to I mean it's like imma get upset I
will show you what upset was all about
it might take a few days for you to
totally understand it but well that's
why I mean you gotta make yo man you
hello sit I might put you in a little
box and just turn it upside down for a
day or so make sure that you're
breathing through the little holes even
put you into water yeah maybe put you
inside a 55-gallon oil drunk and take
the damn lid off and fill it mostly at
the water so you only got a couple of
inches of air you breathe out that
little hole me and you have a whole
conversation we'll see how upset ya see
how upset you don't be like why you
upset wait a minute sir yeah
don't fall asleep in there you seem like
you're getting upset
get upset right then shout tomorrow
maybe yeah you know but yeah all right
so yeah so this woman like I said they
think mostly the other ones were maybe
strangling or suffocation this one
looked like blunt-force trauma and maybe
some stab wounds they thought that she
had probably been killed three to six
weeks beforehand again advanced state of
decomposition but they did they were
able to obtain some fingerprints and
they got some DNA and dental
formation she had actually also been
pregnant when she died although she had
had a miscarriage shortly before she was
murdered they thought she was between 14
and 25 years old again another smaller
woman she was only five foot four about
130 down her 40 pounds slight overbite
some fillings in her teeth indicating
that she had been taken care of at some
point it wasn't like you know her teeth
were well like I said a lot of these
when were not like homeless or anything
like that they look like they had been
cared for at some point in their life
she had pink painted fingernails she had
her hair was actually kind of light
brown but it had like red highlights in
it like she had put red highlights in it
so again that's why they linked her in
with these ones um so she is still
unidentified
uh well actually no she was identified
she was one of the ones that was
identified in late 2018 this woman was
actually turned out to be Elizabeth
Lamont it was 17 years old she had
disappeared April 6 1984 she actually
was identified through a DNA match she
had been staying in a group home in
Manchester New Hampshire and had gotten
a furlough but she hadn't gone back to
her family so I guess they didn't know
where she was so they hadn't really
reported her missing but they did find
out who she was now there were some
other victims that were maybe part of
the series but they're not entirely sure
there was actually a woman that they
just called the rising fawn Jane Doe she
was found in Georgia in 1988 may have
been a victim of the redhead murderer
this is kind of one that a lot of like
people online like on reddit like true
crime stuff like that have kind of tied
to you because even though it was far
away because like I said these are
usually in the Midwest like Kentucky you
know Virginia type region but there were
some other redheaded women that were
murdered you know and left along the
side of highways all these women men
have fallen into the [ __ ] profile of
a girl or a woman that would fall into
into lot lizard uh-huh for you people
who are not Americans what a lot lizard
is is it's an unfortunate I'll call them
unfortunate young woman maybe not so
young all the time they
goes to the damn truck stops in the back
lot all right
to ply her trade you know and sometimes
they will ride with the truck drivers to
go to another truck stop yeah they can
continue to play so they're like mobile
prostitutes
that's what truck not all of them are
mobile but a lot of them are well like
you said that you know the only reason
you know we talk about like truckers the
serial killers but you have to think
that these women you know most truck
drivers are good dudes yeah and they
will just like give them ride you like
to other truck stops like you know the
majority's women don't get murdered say
and the truck drivers just need you know
I mean they get along they need
companionship
oh yeah it's a lonely job yeah and
[ __ ] these girls are doing they're
offering their companionship to these
guys it's a whole [ __ ] scene and
they're making a living at it yeah
what's a lot of have drug problems oh
yeah they're gonna have drug problems so
maybe it's not so much living in terms
of like having a house and a car it's a
living in terms of getting the next fix
yeah that's what they're doing
yeah which like I said it's unfortunate
but mmm you know it seems like a lot of
these women following being homeless
yeah and a lot of women fall into it
because of shitty circumstances they had
like a shitty [ __ ] house bring out a
little way I'm like maybe they're
orphans or maybe their families are
horrible or abusive it tends or
something it tend to come from very
rural areas and the only way out is the
damn local truck stop that's where they
start yeah I walked down a local truck
stop [ __ ] any get the [ __ ] out of
town yeah yeah and unfortunately I'm
talking about some [ __ ] New York call
girl you know that's or [ __ ] Las
Vegas call girl you know that's not what
we're talking about here yeah this is
Len like I said that you know the the
women that this dude targeted are
largely from the Midwest like a
Midwestern or like you know Bible Belt
type of area right so these are kind of
like rural you know it's a rural area
like within these [ __ ] highways you
know truckers just going through a year
and they're not they're usually just
they just usually just don't have the
genes to make it into place like yeah
in Vegas if you're a high quality
[ __ ] girl you want to make a living
you go to [ __ ] Vegas that's where
they all are know if you're a high
quality process you go to Vegas yeah you
know for us to do with a [ __ ] you need
to go to Vegas no I'm just saying high
quality girls no no I would I wouldn't
want to go to Vegas I'm a prostitute
high quality process become a car girl
Vegas yeah la dia porn stars do time
over in [ __ ] Vegas sometimes depends
on if they're on tour or not cuz you're
stripping I mean like I said I think
it's a lot safer nowadays with the
advent of the internet because at least
now you know sex workers can you know if
they have the means to can advertise
online like on Craigslist or whatever
and hopefully be able to like sift
through the features that it is I mean
like I said the Long Island serial
killer that's you know obviously it's
that's not in Vegas that's not how it's
done in Vegas they get dressed up to go
to the [ __ ] casino to go right to the
high rollers table while you're looking
hanging off a guy who's making of all
bunch of money and after he [ __ ] wins
his hand he goes up the [ __ ] room
where there she might stay with him for
a couple days yeah he's putting their
[ __ ] gambling you know that's that's
[ __ ] I was just talking about in
general yeah in general
yeah sex work here not so much Vegas cuz
that's kind of its own thing but depends
on the situation but yeah top-notch
top-notch Vegas girl she's also a porn
star got a name she's gonna go to the
high roller table yeah okay we're
descended $20,000 the [ __ ] game you
know I'm [ __ ] blackjack win yeah
that's so that's right where they're
gonna go
why would you want to be down there with
a rabble why not just go right where the
money is and that's the dudes the
[ __ ] high roller tables and the
[ __ ] casinos know exactly what's
going on more money you mean there get
in there the more money you make on each
transaction the the less time you have
to spend doing it exactly exactly they
go right to that high only is getting 20
big ones per ton yeah no no no
wanna make five thousand and nine ten
thousand and night yes I'm a nice [ __ ]
who's [ __ ] bet and [ __ ] ten thousand
and five thousand a hand that's where
they're gonna go
I just I know the sea it kills me I
can't fathom people that just throw away
$10,000 $20,000 like it was nothing yeah
like I said I'm begging I don't think
I've ever had
ai ai much less twenty thousand I don't
think I've ever had ten thousand dollars
at one time and I used to ever when I
was living in [ __ ] Mississippi down
[ __ ] Biloxi on the [ __ ] Gulf Coast
back before Katrina where all the
casinos were you're not talking about
ten thousand but there were some of
those some of those tables were [ __ ]
running five thousand two thousand three
thousand dollars a [ __ ] hand I was in
there playing roulette crazy and one
time I walked in there with only [ __ ]
$100 and walked out of there with about
1,500 to the night I'll roulette just
betting on red or black which is a loser
game that's a loser game but I [ __ ] I
started doing bread and black and then I
started doing the outsides where there's
three he did two on the ones where you
had a [ __ ] pretty good chance of
winning and okay like a 33 percent
return on it and if you're [ __ ] real
betting on the outsides if you're real
patient I'm talking about gambling we're
in the middle of a [ __ ] show patient
and you don't increase or decrease your
bets you have a very good chance of
[ __ ] continually increasing yours
your your bets by 30% or 33% yeah and if
you're patient and don't break your
rules you can come out ahead now it's
not real consistent just because it's a
lock his gamble it's gambling right and
honestly it's not entirely luck because
the casinos are I mean it's kind of like
waited in their favor ever there's so
many people betting on the table they
can't pick you right another thing is
it's [ __ ] really if you're gonna play
by yourself the best one is [ __ ]
blackjack but that's not the that's not
where you really make the money if you
really want to make the money you don't
want to bet against the house you want
to go to flip the poker table and play
poker that way you're not been against
the house yeah but the house is always
getting something well yeah it's a lot
better if you get playing
[ __ ] of suckers the problem is I'm not a
good poker player I'm not either I'm a
lot better blackjack blackjack and
roulette but that's just like robotic
yeah
blackjack does involve making [ __ ]
decisions but the more decisions you
have to make the more error there could
be unless you're playing against people
and that's but that's that's poker yeah
yeah I mean I used to be good at poker a
long time ago but I haven't I kind of
got you eventually lose yeah it's you
eventually learn by nature I'm just not
so it's for fools yeah and don't ever
[ __ ] go to a one-armed bandit well
now that's that's [ __ ] rigged well
yeah yeah you'll lose you'll lose in a
[ __ ] slot machine that's wrong yeah
well yeah that's like I said if they
want to like waste all their money doing
that [ __ ] like I said I grew up poor man
it's like I don't I don't piss my money
away talking about it makes you want to
gamble like I said I never I think one
time cuz you know I'm from Daytona Beach
if anybody doesn't know and we had I
don't even know if it's still there cuz
I've been dating a couple years but we
stab like the big the dog track like the
greyhound racing and [ __ ] which is
terrible but whatever so I think
something some friends went there and
like I went there and I did actually win
some money like just betting I didn't
know anything about dog racing I just
went through and I was like I just
picked the ones with the coolest names
you know what I mean
and I ended up you know winning a couple
hundred dollars or something and I was
like Oh neat but it's like I didn't I
don't get gambling man I just don't I
don't know I I guess because I'm just -
I know
adrenaline I know what the odds are and
I know that I'm probably gonna lose and
I know that I can't afford it just I've
been I've been to casinos it's just it's
not something that I'm really
comfortable doing certain fun it just
seems like a waste there's a certain
[ __ ] element if I'm gonna waste money
I'm gonna drink it you know I'm saying
no there's a certain element to [ __ ]
glamor it's like something out of
[ __ ] James Bond movie
where you're gonna risk and that I know
I get this adrenaline rush and that's
risky I just don't I don't have that but
you have to understand you have to
understand the [ __ ] odds okay
well yeah I do you have to understand
all the [ __ ] bets but here's the deal
on a blackjack table doing doing [ __ ]
red or black just red or black there's
like a 48% chance you will double your
money yeah so if you had a thousand
dollars and you just happen to put it
either on red or black there's a 48
chance 48% chance that you will [ __ ]
that's damn near 50% well they able to
double your money I know I think man
that's huge yeah that's a huge increase
but see I zoom I'm a glass half empty
person so I'm always kind of like well
that's a fifty two percent chance that
I'll double that money just on that one
bit just walk away from it a made a
thousand but II guess I could take this
I could take - see that's what that's
that's but see I would wait I go I could
take this two thousand I'm gonna take
this two thousand i'ma wait about 20
minutes I don't I go back there again
I'm gonna put it on red and it's just
about a 50% chance that this will become
$4,000 or and it will happen or
sometimes or you can have the time have
a [ __ ] psychic connection with the
[ __ ] a nearly a 50% chance is [ __ ]
very good it's not good enough it's very
good so I got enough for me
it's very good on a good day you could
like I said here's the deal I'm used to
being broke is what I have a little bit
of money I hang on here's the deal you
don't you don't want to you don't want
to bet with money that you can't lose
that's a problem it's gotta be money
that you want to get ugly
okay and then it's just it's just it's
just it is just the way it is times have
I heard about you don't want to do it
regularly if you do this [ __ ] regularly
some dudes get like addicted yeah yeah
yeah and you don't want it and it's just
they'll lose like thousands and hundreds
of thousands their whole ya know like
their whole family is like hey where'd
all the money go oh I pissed it away
gambling but you got it you gotta know
when to say no see I think a lot of
people don't it's like it's an addiction
just like anything
it is well for some people it wasn't
yeah me
well no not for you I mean that but I'm
just saying some people some of you
they love that feel I told you like I
told you if you want to do it for a
living and some guys have done it for a
living you do it on a poker table
because you're not playing against the
house you're playing against individuals
and against other Daniel that is a lot
more in your favor
well yeah because knock you can clean up
yeah and another thing is those guys are
sharks what they do is is that they'll
watch a table and they'll see how the
people are playing and they'll go these
players are weak I'm gonna go in there
and take their money you had a man in
there yeah and then they walk off of it
then they hang out the hangout and hang
out you're seeing the strong players
play and they're gonna play those dudes
and then they see weak players playing
the guy I'm gonna go to that table and
you take their money well yeah that's
not so much a gambling addiction that's
just somebody that's that's sharking
yeah that's circumspect about yeah
[ __ ] they know what they're doing
exactly and that's how you really want
to do it and then in the meantime you
know you can just hang out in the you
can just hang out in the casino and they
got the damn all-you-can-eat buffets and
as you're playing and tip and sometimes
they'll give you here here's see you got
a pass to the buffet oh yeah they give
you free saw they're down there [ __ ]
yeah yeah I think there's no clock so
it's like it's all closed up so you
don't know there's 24 hours a day so
they're living in the [ __ ] casino
pretty much and then they'll go out the
all times they'll have a truck with a
camper on it and they'll go sleep in the
[ __ ] camper yeah then they'll go back
in there and play and then sometimes you
know I mean [ __ ] if they're tipping
well all of a sudden pow they'll go you
know what here's the [ __ ] pass to a
[ __ ] room and then you can go up more
their hotel room yeah well because
that's easy like give they're trying to
get you to lose all your money they want
attorneys but the players know that that
yeah so they're trying to fight the urge
of losing all their money but no guys
that did it
yeah in biloxi yeah yeah and then
they're gamblers that'll see there see
there buddy [ __ ] lose everything and
they're go look here's 300 you're gonna
start over
it's a game gambling again some guys can
build it backed up to [ __ ] $30,000 I
know like I get that like it's tempting
like you know oh I'm gonna go to casino
with like a hundred bucks and like come
out with like a whole bunch it would I'm
just not I'm not well they're practicing
well like I said yeah I'm not realizing
they know all these games yeah and
[ __ ] there's a scene of guys that are
living out of the damn parking lot
trying to make a [ __ ] Raven off a
[ __ ] gambling right and they're they
do where to [ __ ] like one guy oh [ __ ]
he'll he'll win [ __ ] three three
nights and the [ __ ] you know Class B
motel room all right and then he'll go
to his buddies you guys help me out
conquer you stay with me next we did
sentiment so they all person sure yeah
it's a whole scene yeah you know I get
that I get the allure of that yeah it's
just that I guess because there's girls
and these girls men basically so couch
you know I mean very involved in this
same [ __ ] scene
Coop's selling who's selling awesome
look I would love it if they had like a
little neon sign on their couch I get it
yeah like and you know who wouldn't like
to just like walk into a casino with
like a hundred dollars and come out with
like $30,000 yeah be [ __ ] rad happen
but it could happen but I don't know
like I'm I'm kind of a nerd about like
statistics and stuff like that I'm just
like it's so so unlikely that it's like
I just don't want to risk it because
it's like well there's as much out of
this [ __ ] going on - it's like I could
have used that $100 for something else
like there's a bunch of other [ __ ] going
on yes you know - though there's guys
selling drugs in the well yeah the
casino hey man if you move em 400 this
and that and how many of this and now
take you back $500 so I could seal this
[ __ ] cocaine deal okay yeah yeah here
you go
goodbye some cocaine come back tomorrow
I want your money back
they're doing all kinds of [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] I do kind of feel like people that
are into that scene though it's like if
you're here's the thing
if you're kind of like into that whole
gambling addiction thing is something
out of a Stevie Dan album well and well
because and it seems like there's all
this like kind of [ __ ] that's around the
you know they're also like involved in
drugs or they so it's kind of like
there's all these other like unsavory
kind of [ __ ] that's going on it's not
like they're like oh I just made thirty
thousand dollars I'm just gonna go build
a deck on in my house and everything's
gonna be awesome or anything like that
it's always kind of like I'm gonna make
$30,000 I'm gonna blow it on coke [ __ ]
and then the only cookie you know what I
mean it's never anything to buy nothing
comes out of it a lot of times they
don't have anything to buy they're just
pissing it away living their living out
of a [ __ ] camper or they'll fade away
so they don't really need the 30
thousand so what they'll do is they'll
give a thousand to this buddy and a
thousand of that but yeah thirty
thousand because what happen is is that
that person gave him some money before
you know I'm talking about to help him
[ __ ] damn like try to basically
animation and then they start doing kind
of crazy [ __ ] where they go in there
five of them and a blackjack table and
try to [ __ ] count cards and rig the
system in that way oh yeah they so they
do [ __ ] like that - that's how all did
you ever see that big keep track of that
they know yeah about that did you ever
see that movie I think it was called 21
that was about it was a based on a true
story about like a group of it was like
a math professor yeah it turned friend
and there's like trying to like do card
counting like yeah but yeah so um yeah
so he men waiter on the guy win
constantly yeah and then they divide the
money but yeah like I I don't know I
guess I just never so like I can see the
allure of it for some people but I guess
because I don't know it just the way I
grew up it's like I had to hang on to
like every dollar so it's like it never
really appealed to me because it's like
I don't I don't really like spending
money and not seeing something from it
it's like I mean you know the most I
will do it's like yeah I don't mind
spending money on liquor at least I get
drunk off that and like have a good time
but other than that I don't really liked
it I don't even like spending money on
[ __ ] I need you know what I mean it's
like if you
you know what I mean it's kind of like
oh man I need new bras cuz god dammit I
gotta make into maybe $200 on a new
[ __ ] [ __ ] money he died thinking I
don't like to have videos those that
that [ __ ] casino scene they don't
care if they're losing money they don't
really need the money that much they
just want to be in a day they want to be
in that casino and in you know the main
well yeah just want to be in a casino if
I can eat and drink it's just kind of
like me going to I bars yeah I love you
that must be that's what they're doing
and they're all trying to keep each
other in the [ __ ] casino yeah the the
scenesters and [ __ ] you know it's like I
get that just like I said you know it's
it's the same thing with me like I said
go and like the the nightclubs downtown
it's like I'd be bored I just like even
if I don't spend money in there it's
like I like the whole atmosphere only
people there some people are very
susceptible to all this flashing lights
and pretty injury and [ __ ] the sounds
and the [ __ ] emotion I understand it
though I'm not judge it's like a clock
oh yeah I don't have that so good like I
get it though I get it cuz I have the
same thing about just about other things
yeah I'm gonna take a break that are not
you know dumping thirty thousand dollars
which it I don't know I guess it just
makes me mad cuz like I said I've never
had thirty thousand dollars at one time
ever I've never had ten thousand dollars
at one time ever so it just makes me
angry that like people will just go and
just blow this amount of money on
nothing it's like gee why didn't you
just send it to me I could have used
that I could have like bought some
furniture bought something I could have
used but yeah so let's see where was I
cuz okay he went to the bathroom
alright so we're almost done with the
redhead murders thing but all I wanted
to say was that there were some other
possible victims like I said Brezhnev on
Jane Doe from 1988 who was found in
Georgia now she was also a redhead
now she had been raped and strangled she
was between 16 and 25 years old also had
red hair like I said that was why she
was thought to be part of the series
found near Interstate 59
there were some also some other possible
victims there is a woman named Pema
Scott the Pema Scott County doz
we were found in Arkansas in 1978 it was
also one the DeSoto County Jane Doe
found in 1985 the Pulaski County Jane
Doe found in 1985 in Arkansas the how
our how our I'm not sure how you
pronounce that County Jane Doe who was
later identified as Priscilla and
Blevins
you know she so she's one also the Rowan
County Jane Doe found in 1987 Benton
County Jane Doe found in 1990 Hebburn
Jane Doe found in Ohio in 1990 who was
later identified as Patrice Corley she
was identified in 2017 and there was
also a Simpson County Jane Doe in
Tennessee found in 2001 so these people
they're not really sure like I said how
many of these were killed by the same
person like I said I'm not casting
aspersions on all truckers everywhere
but it does seem that several of these
murders probably carried out by the same
person some of them maybe not maybe
there's more than one but it does seem
like a lot of them are truckers just in
the sense that they're driving around
and picking random women up and then
just killing them and leaving them on
the side of the road and not getting
caught so even though this series was
supposedly happen from about you know
1978 1982 somewhere around there to 1992
how many of these are the same person
I'm not entirely sure it's kind of scary
to me that there's more than one driving
around out there but like I said I
honestly had a whole I had old series
that I was just gonna do what was that
noise it's it you didn't break it though
it's been like that it's been like that
for a long time every time I close it
you have to tighten the Allen screw
yeah but like I said so I so I'm not
sure no one's really sure like like I
said they know that the redhead murders
you know that some of these at least are
the same killer which like I said they
call it the Bible Belt stronger
strangler that that name was given by
there was actually
a high school class in Elizabethton
Tennessee and they're kind of like
semester project was to like profile
this [ __ ] whoever the [ __ ] he is
and they gave him the name the Bible
Belt strangler that was several years
after the [ __ ] crime Gillian's in how
you doing Julia hey what's up mm-hmm see
that's why Jenny don't gamble
I don't man Jilly and I requested a
psalm on your [ __ ] channel what song
as you request I wanted to [ __ ] her do
[ __ ] Susie last last beat in my heart
oh that's a good time yeah her voice
would fit that that's a beautiful song
how are you Jay Lynn [ __ ] Jimmy is
probably only about 18 19 maybe you're a
baby yeah she's a baby you could be Mike
she's a baby
yeah you could be my child yeah it's not
[ __ ] crazy to think about I was
talking who was I talking to the other
day that she's 27
you look like you're about 16 17 yeah
all right
I told you I think I might have told
this story before but before the whole
lockdown everyone in fact yeah we were
at a bar and we were hanging out with a
starry night because they had played at
another venue in Orlando earlier they're
from Miami in case they didn't know so
we were like hanging out with them and
I'm talking to Michael goes to the lead
singer and he says to me that he was
born born in 1990 yeah we were laughing
and I was horrified anyway I told him
cuz I didn't really like I knew he was a
lot younger than me the band's older
though they are yeah
but um you know Kay and Howard
especially like cuz he's like into all
the [ __ ] horror movies to me Howard
or [ __ ] I talk and I talked to him like
about horror movies all time to see zone
and our yards Howard's the one who
writes all the music yeah and he's like
our age or maybe a little bit yeah yeah
I was [ __ ] but I'm talking to Michael
and he says he's important to you were
like and I was like a gasps yeah I was
like dude I was like Shh I was like I
grow
high school in 1990 I was like dude
after one of the [ __ ] that was very
funny after one of these you're so cool
though sorry nice shows we go to [ __ ] a
hotel room with him remember that we
were all there in that one room [ __ ]
Howard has his own room
we like I'm not staying away a few
[ __ ] I don't blame them and the
girl the girl that drew the last album
cover she's this real [ __ ] cute
good-looking kind of like goth girl long
black hair she drew the [ __ ] album
cover there's this girl that we also
know she's she's this mother to goth
woman who's about our age okay skinny
little [ __ ] thing and she wanted to
stay remember that yeah she wanted to
stay in the leaving he's like Tom Tom
take her with you and I said come on you
gotta go with us man we brought her back
here to the house she stayed she said
her our guest room and then we took her
to all area the next day right it's
ridiculous
we dropped driver cemetery she's gonna
do some kind of [ __ ] tight jobsite -
but anyway he's like I can't let her
stay here in the room can't let her stay
here that's the call you gotta go she'd
want to leave I'll sleep in the
bathrooms you can't sleep in the
bathroom
what was that once a year or two ago
yeah she she was trying to [ __ ]
groupie out with Michael she had her
eyes set on it but [ __ ] Michael
wasn't interested well he's buried don't
you gave a buddy Kurt you gave up his
seat nobody's supposed to know he's
married I do graphic design work for his
wife own wife owns a salon yeah that's a
really fun my story nights are [ __ ]
super fun band man we love when they
come into town they're super fun and
they always try to try to drag us and
try to get us in did you do the last
album way out or didn't we have a last
album I think it was just a [ __ ] I did
like the one that had that girls aren't
work on it I did like I did the booklet
like she did the artwork obviously but I
did the booklet like I did all the
lyrics into it and I did they got a new
album out now but
don't think it's actually come out in
print I think it was just an online it
might have been yeah so I don't think
they needed this I do a bunch of [ __ ]
for um he has a thing where they do like
online like it's either his wife or
somebody like his parents in-law or
somebody I don't even members to it is
but they have something or they do like
online classes like poor people like it
they get certified for libraries nursing
things like psychological and so I do
like a bunch of graphic design for them
as well so yeah but that they are like
they're [ __ ] funny they are well
that's what I mean it's like they're
they're from Miami but it's like every
now and again like you know not so much
now but like they would usually come up
to Orlando and do a show like once or
twice a year and so they would come up
here and they would stay and then we
would always like hang out with them so
they're always like trying to they're
always trying to get us into trouble
we're trying to get us to like go like
after parties and yeah you try to get in
at most various you try to dig me up on
stage I saw [ __ ] goth out ingesting
stages sing with me that [ __ ] what a
minute
and I was I probably would have done it
but I didn't know other lyrics to all
the songs
you could have just been up there yeah
you could have just winged it
no I didn't know the lyrics you wanted
me to sing it with him winged it way
funny everybody how you do that [ __ ]
come on
no didn't know the lyrics they're always
trying to get put it so I was trying to
give me a douche [ __ ]
yeah well seriously though that [ __ ]
blew my mind when he was talking to me
and I I had forgotten how yeah and I was
like dude you could for real be my kid
because I was like I graduated high
school in 1990 I was 18 yeah and I think
was born and I said like oh my god
people were born and I didn't you get to
our age man everybody seems like little
kids like my since she was 27 that way
she looks 10 years younger than that's
that weird but like I said it's just
funny because I never make you mad Oh
show me some of them [ __ ] flash ball
yeah we did the show we're good she says
sorry I'm late that's well we did the
show a little bit earlier because we
didn't want to interfere if anybody
wanted to like watch fireworks or
whatever so we wanted to get [ __ ] done
before it got dark and also like I said
I didn't want a bunch of fireworks like
going off in the back
we thought we would like to it yeah
[ __ ] Jillian says we'll do it love
Suzy thanks I'm 27 I love you guys my
siblings are between forty and fifty
three yeah so you understand you
understand [ __ ] you know I never
thought I would be this old yeah it
happens man that you can't control it
it's just some time time keeps rolling
forward there's no way to stop it I
tried to always stop
I tried there was nothing I do well like
I said and I think I've mentioned this
on the show before I distinctly remember
being in sixth grade so about 12 years
old and thinking of the year 2000 and
thinking I'll be 28 years old in the
year 2000 thinking it seems so far away
and now I'm like [ __ ] I'll be 48 in
September and I just I don't know I
don't know if I thought I'd be dead but
I'm not really sure but it's like you
don't really think about what its gonna
be like when you're that age they're
asking me when I went goth I didn't go
guys
I just was good yeah it's kind of weird
because it's like I feel like I was just
kind of like I don't really remember
being anything it's like probably I mean
I can say in 84 84 happened 90s when I
was in Brazil and just started coming
across things like [ __ ] Bauhaus
albums and then like a couple years
later started to come across [ __ ]
Sisters of Mercy albums it's just you
know I mean it was gradual it's not like
I just said you know what I'm gonna go
goth no I wouldn't like that it was just
it developed that was just the direction
it's well yeah I think back in the day
was very organic yeah cuz I was
listening to metal music yeah mostly
yeah I [ __ ] love Jewish priests and
like an early Iron Maiden and very early
Metallica and jagdpanzer yog Panzer and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that merciful fate and
for the time that type of metal music
had kind of a gothic flavor to it it did
yeah when you started seeing stuff like
Sisters of Mercy and ba house there
wasn't a big difference in those days
but the metal scene started to go more
female with like [ __ ] BOTS John Bonzo
yeah you got more like mainstream yeah
it started a good out of direction I
didn't like but goth kind of stayed a
certain way and it's kind of it was not
commercial so I just kind of got sucked
down in that direction yeah and it ended
up over time making a little more sense
to me but I'll still go back and listen
to sad wings of destiny or cinnamon or
that's Judas Priest or I'll listen to
[ __ ] Iron Maiden one and Iron Maiden
killers you know the first two albums I
like peace of mind I like some of the
newer Iron Men but as it as I'm a went
on it kind of lost its [ __ ] you know
kind of lost its [ __ ] steam and then I
I liked I liked I liked Metallica but
mostly like the first second third
albums after that it started to get to
commercial cookie when it became when
anything became commercial or mainstream
it got watered down
we're like hipsters before they were
here like as soon as everything goes
mainstream really yeah even before that
was like a thing I was somebody at DJO
maniac says Jenny zarbor goes you I'm
actually a Libra my birthday September
26 so I'm like but when I started going
into goth direction I really started to
go get more into like stuff like David
Bowie and Iggy Pop and a bunch of other
like cool [ __ ] the Velvet Underground
stuff that was goth adjacent I love The
Velvet Underground they were good Nikko
you know and then stuff like death and
June and all that all that like
post-industrial [ __ ] gothic folk you
know yeah like death and June and stuff
I think what happened with me was that I
mean like I said ever since I can
remember I was into horror [ __ ] like as
soon as I could read I wanted ghost
stories which stories like I loved
anything that was like creepy or scary
loved Halloween I loved all that [ __ ]
from before I can remember anything you
know what I mean well from when I was a
little kid it was the black metal band
that had their buddies suicide
oh right that was one of those like
Denmark yeah it was one of those we
talked about them on that bridge on that
show like there wasn't a great band
really it was just they were just
influential in the [ __ ] Norwegian but
the thing about it too is that a lot of
that thing was Norway when in Norway
yeah I think that I think it was
Norwegian a lot of that [ __ ] but I think
a lot of that [ __ ] was like you know the
music in a lot of ways was secondary
they were just trying to like shock
everybody
yeah more than anything it's like look
how [ __ ] up we can be the best of the
black metal bands when you win back with
stuff like merciful fate venom yeah in a
California version which have been
Slayer they were really good but then I
started player actually I like Slayer
quite like Slayer and then but in event
some might say you know Cradle of Filth
but I thought it was kind of played out
by that time you guess it just depends
on how health were kind of poser yeah I
thought so too
I mean that wasn't really my scene but
it's like I always thought they were
kind of I didn't think the quality of
the music was very good it's too fast
well it is something that had already
been done yeah and it seemed like they
were just trying to like ride on the
coattails yeah that had already been
done
it's hard to beat what venom did venom
was kind of like a satanic version of
Motorhead kind of a dread but better and
well not really better it was just
different Motorhead was great Lenny and
Motorhead were [ __ ] fantastic I loved
that bad
everybody loves Motorhead well there was
a certain amount of [ __ ] his street
wisdom in [ __ ] lemme lemme would tell
you he was a straight shooter he would
tell you what was on his mind
yeah well like I said that's why
everyone chipped that's why everybody
loves murder yeah
how can you know let murder it it's good
it's kind of like not liking the Ramones
yeah you know what I mean it's just kind
of like who doesn't love the Ramones
come on yeah it's one of those kind of
things but yeah so I don't know I kind
of feel like my whole childhood was like
I loved spooky [ __ ] I loved horror [ __ ]
and then when I was 11 or 12 I heard the
cure and this was probably had on the
door no earlier the walk it was around
the walk time was
was 82 so I would have been about 10 so
I heard that I remember it and I heard
that and I was just like holy [ __ ]
there's a whole subculture of people who
were into the same [ __ ] that I'm like
which blew my mind because I thought it
was just me thank you Joe no question no
question
I remember I remember I remember the
cure when I was a kid in military school
but yeah I think the walk was the first
casino cute yes the first cassette let's
go to bed see we didn't have that we
didn't look I grew up in Daytona Beach
was just like I had Cara we heard let's
go to bed that was the first thing I
remembered I son at MTV and also the
very first Duran Duran like planet Earth
oh my god I don't love Duran Duran yeah
well like I said I got into Duran Duran
like earlier than that because like I
said I think my whole thing into goth
was New Wave because I was into David
Bowie I was into like modern English
Psychedelic Furs [ __ ] like that and then
like I kind of started getting into like
the cure Depeche Mode alien sex fiend I
was kind of getting into that I was got
into Bauhaus and stuff like when I was
you know maybe early teens yeah that
year before I went into the army I was
living when I was living in - in Detroit
skinny puppy would come across the
[ __ ] border from Ontario and play at
a club I used to hang out at called the
shelter it also played at Sandra's hall
actually I think they played an ant's
Tanger Hall not shelter and but I would
run into cabin key and those guys at the
shelter they were older than me though I
couldn't talk to them they were much
cooler than me back another well no they
were [ __ ] basically minor celebrities
I was a kid nobody in those days but I
used to see him and there are a lot of
weird bands in the Detroit scene at that
time that's why the crow was set in
Detroit because before that time there's
a lot of weird goth industrial stuff
there's one that they used to have a
used to see it all the time - Trish
called kitten with a whip and that was a
[ __ ] weird man it was like Skinny
Puppy that was a movie it was on MST
called John war safe within a war this
neat these neon orange and neon green
tights like something out of a [ __ ]
popsicles or something like a push-ups
and the head [ __ ] he knows flashing
yo-yos they used to have yeah it hit
that [ __ ] stuck down in [ __ ] crotch
with their dicks worse so there's
[ __ ] lights shining out and have
motorcycle helmets in Atlanta and when
he came out on stage I had a [ __ ]
look like a pink [ __ ] poodle with
antennas like a fake Pete poonam poodle
with a Dennis on a skate built on a
skateboard and they walked it out on a
damn leash and [ __ ] it's just weird
[ __ ] man and there was a lot of prop
practice and stuff going because I guess
I mean when I was kind of growing up and
I was 17 or 18 like my I have a brother
well I have two brothers but I have a
brother who was four years younger than
me and he was like in a bunch of punk
bands and believe it or not in Daytona
there were actually a couple of venues
where punk I mean they were tiny but
like there was one called combat zone it
was one called
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was the name in that
place that I remember it was like a
coffee house or something and they did
have like some you know punk bands play
there and he had a little punk band that
was called what was called a jell-o bone
for a while and it was called some they
were actually quite good and they were
very very into the props I feel like
that was kind of like a big thing like
maybe it was cuz aguar you know I mean
I'll get done with this show I mean
probably I was gonna say one more thing
about just wrap that up because people
are talking about things okay so let me
just say that like Bible Belt strangler
the dude that was responsible to red
head murders like I said 2018 there was
a high school sociology class in
Elizabeth's in High School in Tennessee
and they came up with a profile of the
Bible Belt strangler the likely Bible
Belt strangler and they gave it to the
FBI who said that it was yes probably
very accurate they think this is a dude
that was a white male obviously because
all the victims were right probably born
between 1936 and 1962 so aged between 23
and 49 years old in 1985 point at the
height of the murders probably a
commercial trucker frequenting
Interstate 40 they think that this dude
probably had some like trucker thing
was like yet per pod we had hi oh thank
you very much Anil a thank you very much
man you shown us those flash balls
probably had high cholesterol like other
things that go wrong along with like
sitting around doing truckin probably
they think that he was a trucker that
was based out of Knoxville Tennessee so
be on the lookout for somebody like that
because they think that that's who did
some are all of these redhead murders so
all right where were you going now we
can go back to the [ __ ] yeah that was
there was a lot of stuff even to happen
back in the eighties back when I was
hanging out man ray in Boston you guys
remember [ __ ] tear garden the tear
guard thank you thank you very much
thank you Matt Tom what's your favorite
video favorite video game fallout
okay well [ __ ] over all over all or just
favorite video game in the 80s favorite
video game of the 90s you have to have
yes yeah more specific well why don't
you just give an answer for each of
those things okay
favorite video game of the 80s probably
would have been Spy Hunter all right
favorite video game of the 90s no [ __ ]
maybe skip that one if he can't think of
one yeah got a drunk I had stopped
playing video games by that time so I'm
not really sure favorite video games of
the night probably would have been I
don't know man [ __ ] yeah I can't
answer that question let's counsel mean
there were so many good was that wasn't
90s though I remember Castlevania that
was good that was like shinobi that was
a good one yeah there's a lot of stuff
that was good there's my mom 64 my most
recent favorite one like I haven't
played it but I like watching you play
fallout yeah I like actually I was
fallout 4
the fallout sir yeah the fallouts are
good I can just I can just sit there and
watch you like decorator yeah apartment
I also like the Mad Max video game that
came out a couple years back that was
really good um back in the 80s I was
also big into battle zone was big in The
Tempest
it was just a lie it was just for some
reason I liked it but I wasn't that good
at it and Burger Time another one that I
was I liked the weird concept another
one I was good at was I was good at and
I liked it was wizard of war yeah that
was a good one then ended up getting
into Strider the very first Strider game
ever moon Patrol
yeah yeah I remember that warf warf
where it was a mixture of everything was
like space invaders at Galaxian and all
the crazy they're like whatever we're
just remember saying if the member
Phoenix yeah yeah that was a trip
Phoenix was this [ __ ] trip and then
they came out with like a [ __ ] sequel
to it called Pleiades yep yeah that one
too yeah
well cuz here's the thing I remember one
of my favorite things to do when I was a
kid this is so 80s you guys one of my
favorite things doing was a kid was
gonna the skating rink in the skating
rink at an arcade so you could like your
mom and dad would drop you off at the
skating rink on the [ __ ] get ready
and you well yes they don't want you
around so you would just like hang out
and it was like a little there was a
snack bar there was pizza there was
video game she could skate to [ __ ]
Jay geils Band
oh damn [ __ ] [ __ ] John Deere
Mellencamp you just like having a good
time all day long you remember sack song
yeah yeah the [ __ ] control stick had
to fly that [ __ ] looking Space
Shuttle and fly it down through the
[ __ ] enemy base she is axe huh it's
like I said I kind of like I kind of um
you know went off videogames maybe like
in the 90s after we got a home computer
like I played [ __ ] like you know when we
got our first home computer like in 95
or whatever it was we had like some
games that were like PC games and my dad
bought like King's Quest and that kind
of [ __ ] which I liked and I played that
all the time I loved like Tetris and all
this kind of puzzle games I had went to
you that was like a I can't run with the
name
but it was like an Edgar Allan Poe type
of game or like you went through this
[ __ ] like a dungeon or some kind of
[ __ ] and you had it was like trivia you
had to like - you had to solve puzzles
like trebuchet and I like that but it's
like after that I don't know I just went
off and did other [ __ ] so I didn't
really like they're talking about n64
and yeah in 64 the [ __ ] winner was
Goldeneye I [ __ ] loved Goldeneye
everybody says that was one of the best
of the best
the problem with Goldeneye on n64 is
that it was a one choice TIF controller
okay so you can fire just by looking in
the right direction but if you wanted to
aim you had to press the [ __ ] trigger
button and it would zoom in and then you
could aim so it wasn't a - controller it
wasn't a - joystick controller see I'm
not coordinated enough to made it hard I
would love to have [ __ ] Goldeneye for
Xbox - but because of Licensing they
weren't able to really have an emulator
for that yeah not that I know of
now the same guys who made gold and I
came out with another game called
perfect dark witch oh yeah which is the
same engine it's very much a game and I
have that you can get that for Xbox one
and that's pretty fun to play but
there's nothing to like but there's
there's nothing he's really hard to beat
Goldeneye with the James Bond theme song
and the guns that they had and it now
they tried to come out with a different
they did come out with a different
version of it but you can't play it on
Xbox one it's only for Xbox
I think 360 and they didn't they didn't
[ __ ] release it for Xbox one on till
on downloadable you can get the disc but
I don't think it works it's a total
reboot of it they're supposed to which
it's it's not it's it's just more like
Call of Duty yeah I want that original
Goldeneye gameplay which was real slick
and simplified you know I mean wasn't
real it wasn't real detailed or
realistic it was [ __ ] kind of
cartoonish it just made it an awesome
game hitting the playability was very
very good they keep promising
that they're gonna release a new
Goldeneye for Xbox one that will be
playable that will be pretty much the
same game just very updated so but if
you liked Goldeneye and you have the
Xbox one just get a perfect dark gets
real close yeah real close yeah because
I've seen you playing like I said I
don't really have a lot of time to play
video games anymore
I do like fallout I do like you know you
like the Tomb Raider games as well cuz
just like you know yeah so I like
puzzled oh yeah I love tomb all I love
all the tumor like a puzzle type games
more than like shooter type games
although I used to play Doom back in the
day Karen says duck hunt I used to love
[ __ ] duck on yeah honestly my
favorite games back in the day Tetris
duck hunt Castlevania Sonic the Hedgehog
I like that
Zelda Zelda the or Konya of time I mean
ocarina of time for n64 was a fun
[ __ ] game I don't know if it holds up
it's been a long time since I played it
but back in the day it was fun
yeah we I mean me and my brother used to
play video games all the time but it's
like we had we had the Nintendo we had
to say go we had all I got [ __ ] there's
some about the nineties games they were
complicated but they weren't overly
complicated and they had a lot of soul
to them I don't know you don't I mean I
think the only thing kind of close to
that that I found recently would have
been like flames there's a certain
amount of soul to them to know but you
know each game is its own thing I think
the thing that I loved about fallout
well I love the whole aesthetic of it
like I love the retro you know
post-apocalyptic yeah you know from a
graphic design standpoint I just really
loved like that whole is that idea it's
cool but um to me it's just I love that
it's a whole entire world you can
immerse yourself in and I honestly I
enjoy watching you just wandering around
yeah like in the wasteland like just you
and nothing yeah it's like for some
reason it's like that's really relaxed
it's also kind of like really
interesting I don't know because it
kills me that some that there's so much
because you know like I said I'm not a
game designer but I'm a graphic designer
I've done like a lot of [ __ ] along those
lines so I know how much work it takes
to construct this entire ya world so I
know how much work goes behind that so
it just like blows my mind like how you
can just like wander around this [ __ ]
whole entire universe and I kind of try
to think to myself like you know how
could I create like a whole [ __ ]
world like that you know what I mean so
it's just kind of like it kind of blows
my mind that it's just like so vast yeah
you know what I mean so that [ __ ]
kills me well I think it's probably the
end of the show now I probably got
everything done questions really hello
yeah we've been go to over three hours
yeah it's over three hours holy crap it
went really really fast and it is kind
of getting dark I wonder if people are
gonna like start like blowing [ __ ] up
now okay let's go ahead and let's go
ahead and show them you gonna end it
yeah alright guys thanks for uh thanks
for showing up and [ __ ] spread the
word like share subscribe and we'll see
you guys in a couple days yeah when's
our next stream Oh
next we'll probably do one tomorrow I
wanted to talk about the unsolved
mysteries alright yeah
series will probably do a review stream
out tomorrow guys we'll talk to later
so probably be about two blocks
afternoon Eastern Standard Time like as
we usually do alright um but yeah so
thank you everybody for stopping by I
can't believe we've been on for over
three hours yeah with this but you know
it's a show it was that a good time
we'll see you soon
but yeah so um we will see you guys next
time like I said probably tomorrow we'll
do another livestream will probably be a
shorter one like a movie review type
thing um but so thanks everybody for
something bye like share subscribe like
you do and we'll see you tomorrow bye